Doon doon,
Doon Doon,
Doon Doon doon teaching dunk in the ways
of windows laptop.
Fucking love it.
Max Keyboards can go fuck themselves.
Those are terrible keyboards.
They're not designed for comfort and
writing.
This whole idea of getting thinner man
get thinner and thinner.
So it's a piece of paper and it
magically unfolds that expanse the right
side.
This is fucking.
This is not too thick.
Yeah.
How come they can do it?
Well,
how come you guys can't do it?
Why?
How come you only offer one shitty ass
fucking keyboard?
Find out if your map will qualify for
apples.
Keyboard repair program.
I don't want you to repair the same
shitty keyboard.
I want you to make a real keyboard where
you have like,
it's got like a little bit of a u shape
to it.
Where you finger that goes into the
center.
What does that call?
How do they describe that?
And the keys have like a little,
a little bit of a dip to them.
And then in the middle you feel where
they are?
Yeah.
Dimpled.
Perhaps you feel where they are.
They have travel so your fingers know
what's going on.
You get tactile feedback,
more tactile feedback.
Then this little clickety click thing,
which might as well be.
You might as well be doing it on an
ipad.
You know you have an ipad keyboard and
it kind of works,
but it kind of doesn't because your
fingers are all feeling the same thing
every time.
One individual buttons and give you
individual feedback so you don't have to
think about what's happening.
You could just think about the words.
It feels like this.
They hired an alien at apple that forgot
that.
Humans like to push buttons.
We like it.
It feels good.
It feels good though.
They're.
They're ignoring like a basic human
drake,
which is like,
have you seen those dumb cubes?
Nervous people get.
They've got like buttons and Shit and
you spin it around.
It's the same thing.
It's like gives you this tactile little
thing where you take all that extra
energy and you put it in your.
In your stress ball.
Your people liked it.
Punch,
impress and click and switch and that's
what apple forgot.
It's like when I'm typing man,
I like that.
I like like in the shining.
When you hear that means I'm typing.
I like the sound,
the flutter of the keys as you're
writing that fucking apple keyboard.
Man.
When I went in I was so ready to buy a
brand new Mac book pro,
so excited.
Really excited like five minds from like
2014 or 2015.
I mean,
not to like be in fucking apple fanboy,
but I will say that when I,
when I went in there with it instead of
trying to sell me the new Mac book,
she looked at it and was like,
what are you doing on the thing?
And I'm like,
oh,
I edit sound.
And she was like,
Ma,
I don't know that you,
that you even need a new and outside of
the fact that it's new.
Whoever you are,
young lady
Odin
blesses you and blesses you and blesses
you for your,
your,
your truth.
Yeah.
It was for your wisdom,
dude.
I was so shocked.
I always tell them to eat.
We don't need the computing power.
I was stunned,
man,
because like I've never in that,
that moment is kind of made me
perpetually love apple because they're
training their employees not to like,
just like pressure sell shit,
but just to actually help the customer
out of stock.
She could sell you one.
Anyway,
she was just like,
dude,
you don't even want one.
She's probably quitting.
She's quitting.
Just sick of her job for the last four
days.
She's been telling everyone no matter
what they came in to buy it.
She's like,
you know,
you don't need this.
Her boss has been saying creepy shit to
her.
She's been ready to quit for a while.
I was an asshole.
Yeah,
yeah.
No.
Okay.
Mark.
I'm going to go out in the floor and
Mark Jessica,
I've noticed your sales have gone to
zero.
Okay.
Move those new laptops.
Well,
yeah,
he sure.
Mark.
Mark's got a creepy wink.
Yeah.
Can you get away with that at work?
What can you do now?
What if you're like,
hey,
susie,
make sure you have that copy done to
personnel by two.
No,
can't do that.
You can't wink and go,
hey,
you definitely can't do the gun.
Nope.
Unless you're doing it to everybody.
If you're in a meeting,
you could go pet.
You're a mass shooter.
Oh,
I can't do it to one person,
to a group of people.
You can't make the finger gun anymore.
The finger guns gone.
You can't do I,
I,
you know,
I'm,
we're both.
We have cool jobs due to like,
I have to imagine that that's gone.
Like you know,
my house,
the finger guns,
not guns.
That guy shoot my dogs every day in
front of my wife.
I like looking at her cavaliers and
being like,
Bam,
Bam.
Now what?
I can't even play around.
I love those done.
It's like there's no room for new ones
because there are crazy people to do
shoot people.
You can't pretend to shoot people
anymore.
Dude,
this is it man.
This is exactly the fucking problem of
being interconnected by technology is
that we are paying for the sins of the,
of the small percentile of absolute dumb
ass is on the planet.
And because of that there,
you know,
anytime I look at a sign,
any sign that's got like an obvious
thing in it,
don't,
don't shed in the hot tub or like on the
roller coaster,
don't,
don't get out of your seat.
When I look at that,
I think that's because a dumb,
dumb dumb because there might be a
person who's in the roller coaster,
like,
will be more fun.
Didn't do it mean to do a southern
accent.
By the way,
I'm from the south.
I don't think they're all done.
This is too many people dogging.
There's too many people talking in this
world.
Didn't use to be like that.
This is a new thing
for the last 10 years.
People started talking.
Yeah.
Nope.
The,
the average person didn't ever voiced 20
years ago.
There's great things to anyone having a
voice crate thing.
Great,
great things.
But we're going to have to relearn human
communication,
right?
We can't use the old rules for today.
It just can't work.
He can't work and it's too easy to be an
asshole.
People got to stop seeking that out.
Like I the lashing out at people for no
reason.
It's so crazy how many people do it.
You'll see someone post something and
someone will be like,
fuck you.
You dumb piece of shit.
Don't you realize that this is why this
and why that any.
You know,
Steven Kotler,
he's been on this show a few times.
He's awesome and they're doing these,
doing this new psychedelic study,
psychedelics and flow states.
So I retweeted a tweet because he,
he's like,
they're doing research right now.
They need people to fill out a survey.
So I retweeted that to help steven out.
Just like,
ah,
cool.
Yeah,
that's a cool thing.
I think psychedelics probably do induce
flow states.
I'd like to find out for sure,
but within like six comments,
it's still up there if y'all want to
look.
Some dude wrote to me something on the
lines of like,
you're hurting people and don't even
know it.
That six down.
It's like hurting people.
I can't remember what language he used,
but it's like,
what the fuck you.
This is a survey dude.
Like what are you talking about?
Like is it maybe he means by re tweeting
surveys,
that sucks because no one wants to see
that on their timeline,
but I think he meant you're hurting
people by demystifying and de
stigmatizing psychedelics.
Little do you know you're fighting cruel
funding.
Funding cruelty.
I'll locally just said,
huh?
Because I want the explanation because
it's like when someone says something
like that,
it's so terribly absolutely impossibly
wrong from my reality tunnel that it's
like I want to get narrow reality tunnel
and here because that guy really that he
believes it well or he's a troll.
It could be he's a troll.
It could be that each had terrible
experiences with psychedelics.
That's,
you know,
maybe he's one of those guys that had a
real,
you know,
look,
when people get really into something,
they want everybody to get into it.
I'm a terrible example that I'm telling
everybody.
Got Into Yoga,
Yoga,
do yoga.
Yeah.
This happens with,
with everything.
Oh,
and people that get sober,
like people that have a real problem to
have.
Like we all know someone who's gone off
the deep end with drugs,
right?
When they come out of that,
some folks turned into evangelists for
sobriety.
Yeah,
and it gets super annoying.
Yeah.
One of the things they do is they
demonize all positive experiences that
we're with the
same substances,
their negative experience,
and they're fucking crazy head.
They've decided because they had a bad
trip.
Every trip is bad.
The millions of people tripping all over
the world,
taking mushrooms,
finding God and love and companionship
and harmony with the universe and an
acceptance of their mortality.
All that doesn't count because billy
couldn't keep his shit together at the
pink Floyd concert because this fucking
asshole decided to eat the entire,
the entire bag of mushrooms and he
tripped his balls off and was screaming.
They had to take her to the hospital any
and he called his ex girlfriend and
cried to her for hours and now her
boyfriend,
a new boyfriend wants to beat him up and
he doesn't even remember doing it.
Like,
that guy guy's an idiot.
Okay.
There's a lot of those people out there.
All lot of them,
a whole lot of them and there's people
that just aren't geared for psychedelics
for whatever reason.
You know,
there's people that are really,
really close to losing their shit with
regular reality.
For sure.
For them it's not a good idea.
It's not a good idea.
Absolutely.
That's definitely something that like in
my old age,
I want to put in like at Tallix and
underlying.
That's what you just said because when I
was younger,
when you're younger and you are in that
evangelical part of your psychedelic
life,
you can become like,
if you're not careful,
ridiculous and irresponsible and you
start throwing out there this like idea
that is not only fundamentally wrong,
it's fundamentally wrong in everything
as far as I'm concerned,
which is there's not really a one cure
to your troubles.
You know what I mean?
So,
but with psychedelics,
people think this is the answer,
this is the answer,
this is it,
this is what we need.
And it's like,
well,
it's part of what some people need,
but if you've got manic depression,
for example,
if you've got bipolar,
you know,
dude,
I had this moment where this,
uh,
some parents came up to me and were dead
tell you about this there.
They came in to talk to me.
I'm at a show and they were like talking
about how their kid,
like my podcast.
And it was really sad because he had
been at one of my podcasts and I think
he'd come onstage as a question or
something or,
and they were looking for a recording of
the live show because they thought maybe
they could hear him talk or get some,
like as in laughter or something.
But anyway,
what happened was he,
uh,
I think he had some kind of.
I'm bipolar,
I'm not sure what,
but he's one of my friends rave and he's
like,
is he uses the term gyro is gyro is off
a little bit,
you know,
something was off a little bit.
But anyway,
the kid went and did Iowaska in Peru.
He did a eight night or wanting to know
how they're doing these.
I don't know how they do it every night
or every other night,
eight retreat,
drinking
the medicine every night and then after
that went to some kind of like other
shaman or some woman,
I don't know who it was,
I'm not sure of the dates,
but then he came home and he jumped off
a waterfall and killed himself because,
because what had happened is he a man,
he was in a manic state.
It triggered a manic state,
um,
and he killed himself and,
and,
and that was Iowasca,
you know,
that's like the medicine,
right?
And,
and so it just,
for some reason I think some people are
deemphasizing what it means to be healed
by the psychedelic or to be worked on by
a psychedelic or to enter into that
state because it's becoming,
thank God,
a De stigmatized.
Much more so.
Do you remember how it was 20 years ago?
Dude?
It was.
You couldn't even talk about it.
Couldn't talk about it,
couldn't mention it.
It was you.
It was bad,
bad,
bad drugs.
It was heroin.
It was on the same level as like you,
if you were taking Lsd,
that was like heroin man,
so people will look at you like you're
crazy and then there's also,
you know,
there's real problems that people have
with being tested at work.
A lot of people get tested at work and
people worried about losing their jobs,
so drugs don't just become a thing where
you could fuck up and you know and get
addicted to them,
but now they become a thing that could
take away your livelihood,
take away your livelihood.
That's right.
Check your pee.
They put the state of paranoia on their
employees.
Just imagine that feeling.
You're working for some office.
You probably don't dig the GIG anyway,
right?
You don't even like it and they have to
check your pass every now and then.
That didn't only,
you know when.
Duncan,
can I see you for a moment?
Hi.
In high.
It's that time of the year.
Random drug tests.
So I'm just going to have to go with you
and watch you pull your penis out and
put it into this cup and give me a
little sample of your body fluids.
Okay,
baby.
Okay.
Yeah.
That didn't work anymore.
What if they figured a way around it so
they had to collect your shit.
I need to see you.
Shit.
See Your asshole opened up and I need to
see that tube come out into this
tupperware container.
I'm going to be there.
Yeah,
that'd be.
Thank God in a way.
Thank God.
That's how they detect drugs.
Thank God it's through the pis.
Thank God.
It's not like you,
you know,
like probably.
I don't know this for sure,
but I bet every asshole has a thumb
print.
Like you know,
everybody has a different thumbprint.
I bet if you took asshole prints,
every human would also have like a
different asshole print and like cheap.
Imagine if that was true.
If like you could see foot in
fingerprints like oh look,
it gives you the ingredients.
This guy's like 60 percent asshole.
It says that we just didn't look at
this.
No,
I don't mean asshole.
I mean the literal asshole.
Oh,
like if you take a person's asshole and
put like and you're like,
oh,
like an asshole print.
Like retina squinted on ink.
Yeah,
it's the brown eye.
Retina scan.
Everyone.
Wow.
For sure.
Probably the asshole as a thumbprint.
It's just simply for sure.
Sure.
So if you took psychedelics and it
caused that thumbprint and change a
little bit and that's how they told
where it's.
They don't want to look at your shit.
You just have to.
They have to look at like you're either,
they have to scan your ass in the print
change.
You didn't Mescalin whew,
we're lucky it's in the piss.
But.
But also if you really think about the
fact that we are in a world where people
have to go to work to do a job,
that by the way,
man,
if there is a dude you need to get on
this podcast and there's a book that you
would love.
David Graber wrote this book called
Bullshit Jobs.
This guy is a fucking genius man in this
book.
Bullshit jobs breaks down the phenomena
of how many,
many people are working in jobs that
don't do anything for the world or the
company they're working for.
And it's not like this judgmental thing
where he's like,
yeah,
that's a bullshit job.
You're a blah,
blah,
blah.
He's one of the,
he's like an anthropologist.
So he's very precise.
But one of the qualifications for your
job to be a bullshit job is you know,
that it's really kind of a worthless
job.
It's not really doing anything.
And like companies have gotten so
fucking big that,
uh,
they,
they end up having like departments or
people running departments or extra
employees that don't really need to be
there at all and they have to pretend to
be,
to work.
That's what he writes about.
He writes it that if you really want to
torture a person,
uh,
not only give them,
like the job of like,
you know,
pouring a glass of water and an empty
glass and pouring it back,
but then add to it that they have to
deceive their boss into thinking that
they're doing an important job or they
lose their jobs.
So these not only are these,
like some corporations and companies
scanning your pes to see if you're
taking a substance that is allowing you
to connect with home what you actually
are.
They are also demanding that you spend
many hours a day lying to them that
you're doing work that you're not doing,
like if you're fucking efficient,
you know,
and this is another thing I graybar
writes about.
Forgive me,
David Graver,
if in any way I've misconstrued as I
read your writings stoned,
but the,
the,
um,
the other fucking element to it that is
absolutely atrocious and fucking
horrible is that these substances are
connecting us to home.
They don't want us to be in those states
and they're asking us to fucking lie all
day.
And you know what psychedelic means?
The,
the etymology of psychedelic.
No,
it means mind manifesting or soul
manifesting,
right?
So a psychedelic connects us potentially
with the truth,
what we are,
our identity,
right?
And these companies,
they're asking us to lie,
to be the opposite of our identities,
to wear weird a suit or,
or some kind of dress code.
And to sit in a desk where because
you're efficient,
you get your job done in 45 minutes and
for the next six hours you got to sit
and type in,
pretend that you're working,
knowing you're a person and knowing that
this is like unethical,
you're.
But if you,
if you like go and tell your boss,
hey man,
I don't really have much to do,
you might get fired.
The boss might like in the book he cites
one person because he did like a survey
and he cites one person who went to her
boss and she's like,
Hey,
I can finish my job in two hours.
I need,
can I have other stuff to do?
And her boss is like,
don't talk about that.
Stay quiet about that.
Oh yeah man.
That's the fucking world we're in right
now because of automation.
There's less to do.
Computers are making shit fat.
It's why are we were working the exact
same amount of time we were when there
were no computers,
but you have to be there to get paid and
you have to act like you're doing
something or they can use.
Yeah.
So many people right now are doing just
that while the list of this a lot,
a lot,
and by the way,
if you had to guess what percentage of
people are listening right now that are
really supposed to be doing some
bullshit job and they're kind of sitting
in front of their keyboard with earbuds
on,
just barely paying attention.
Try not to get caught looking at porn.
Yeah,
I probably an all over the planet at
over a million.
Over a million in the work
forest probably.
When do you think companies had to put
in rules?
You can't look at porn at work.
Like that wasn't a thing in the
seventies who wasn't a thing in the
eighties.
It wasn't a thing in the nine,
zero s then all the sudden you could
just find porn online and people will.
They have a work computer that's hooked
up to the Internet.
Like when did the company start going?
Oh yeah,
we didn't know about that.
Yeah,
you can't look at that
dude.
And I mean I'm sure it started with like
Penthouse,
right?
Like even when they have penthouse
penthouse magazine,
like when you had fucking like,
you know for sure you couldn't bring
your pen out of your fucking hustler to
work.
That's true.
But the but looking at something online
is so much easier than going to the
store and getting a hustler.
Like the access is universal,
instantaneous.
Everyone has the ability to just go and
download it,
you know,
if we're going to like ask questions
that are impossible to answer.
Like how many people right now do you
think listening to the podcast or in
their bullshit job jerking off to while
they
listened?
At least one dude.
But yeah,
for sure.
That's what dudes do.
Yeah,
I mean because you can get away with it.
They jerk off.
Especially a guy with a bad job who
could find a way to jerk off somewhere.
Let me just five minutes in this
bathroom with jerk off.
Just think about the stupid fucking job.
Dude.
Come on.
Like that's like sexual assault.
I don't think off in an office.
Not In the what if you scream,
if everyone knows the going to go great.
Hey,
I'm going to go in there,
I'm going to jerk off and when I come I
scream that sexual assault.
Oh for.
Well that is.
I fucking feel like suing you right now,
man.
Fucked up.
You work with some guy and he's like 300
pounds and you're like 150 pounds and
you're like,
hey man,
I need to figure out how to fix this
computer.
We're going to have to unplug everything
for what?
He goes.
Okay,
cool.
I'm going to go in the bathroom.
I don't want to jerk off.
And when I come I scream.
Dude,
I don't know.
I even have to add the scream too.
And it's like,
I mean I,
I think Santa for
a dude,
it's a terrible prospect.
I think it's interesting too because
when you consider like the act of
shitting versus the act of jerking off
is like far more repulsive.
You're,
you're expelling like foul smelling
toxins from your body into the toilet.
And if you say to your friend,
Hey,
I gotta go take a shit man,
he,
your friends probably going to be like,
well,
you didn't need to tell me that.
Like,
okay,
I don't,
but,
but he,
but your friend's not going to be like,
Whoa Dude,
what?
And yet jerking off,
really if you think about it,
it's like you're giving yourself a
hamish massage the end,
just like a little spray of like cream
coming out it horrific.
It's like,
it's like what?
But in our culture,
like,
no,
don't do it at the office.
My God,
John,
don't do it here.
John.
I'm just picture John just with an itchy
trigger finger just ready to reach into
his pants.
No,
no John.
No.
Did you do it again John?
It's a gross relationship that the
worker has now with the corporation and
it's an unnatural relationship and it's
a relationship that seems to have like
dehumanized people to the point of being
automatons that don't have a sex drive,
that don't deserve to be able to explore
their consciousness.
And um,
this is uh,
a real problem.
And
I'd already told me what he studied the
Talmud and did it for like 12 hours a
day when he was a young,
young man.
He told me that there was one passage
where in one of the ancient texts where
it was talking about battling a dragon
and he said,
he's like,
this doesn't make sense because
everything in here is supposed to be a
story that actually
happened.
Like what is this dragon?
Or The dragon is a metaphor for
masturbation.
They tell them.
So the dragon that takes away young
boys.
This is,
it is.
It is a metaphor for masturbation.
Dan talked about this on the podcast.
Yes,
dude,
it's,
you know,
Ari knows about as much as anyone you're
ever going to meet about Orthodox Jewish
traditions and the religion and the,
the tax.
He really did study that shit every day.
Twelve hours a day for year in Israel,
right?
Yeah.
So when he tells you about it and he got
the,
he got the actual translation of the
metaphor from a guy who's a scholar.
Yeah,
Dude.
Yeah.
That's a bad metaphor.
That's like,
I think like if I wanted for whatever
reason to dissuade people from jerking
off,
I could come up with a way better like
thing than a dragon to represent it,
you know,
there'd be some other thing like a,
I don't know,
man,
like what's like,
uh,
what,
what would be like the creature version
of a rolled up ball of dried come that
you've thrown next to your bed and
someone walks into your bedroom and sees
the rolled up ball of dried come clean x
and it's just kinda like,
that's gross.
You didn't clean up your common clean x.
It would be like one of them ghostbuster
villains,
right?
Some sort of plasma thing that just
Jesus all over,
you know,
they'd get ghostbusters.
What do you think about the Antifa
movement?
Anti-Fat movement?
FAP,
fap.
Oh No,
no,
jerking off.
Yeah.
No fat.
Not anti-fat and diagnosed at different.
Moving.
Well,
there's good and bad.
The good thing is sex will be way more
pleasurable.
The bad is it'll be way more desirable
so like to,
to mitigate your sexual urges so you
don't do stupid things and hanging out
with stupid people,
have sex with people you don't really
like but you think are hot because
you're horny and they're willing,
which is a lot of people they get,
they get wrapped up in these
relationships with these guys and gals
that they're not really in love with,
but they like to fuck,
you know,
I'm,
it's like,
what do you think about it?
Well,
I think that there,
you know,
was something I always think back on is
when you were sponsored by fleshlight in
this is when we were doing the podcast
from your house and you'd come to do
your podcast and you'd walk away with a
flashlight.
So I ended up with like three or four
flashlights.
And like at first I just wanted like,
you had different types and at first I
just went for like,
oh the one that looks like a pussy.
Right?
But then like,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
I got that one.
But then you have like one that was
like,
I don't know,
man,
like some kind of like garlic oil alien.
It was really nice.
It was really fucking weird man.
But anyway,
you know,
I fuck those things.
And,
and uh,
and,
and I,
when I think back to it,
it's like the first time I did it,
it tricked my brain.
The second time or third time I did it,
it wasn't getting the same effect.
Whereas when I have sex with a human,
it's a completely different.
It feels like it's a completely
different series of chemicals that must
be being released in my mind
uniting with someone you're bonding with
someone,
you certainly get the oxytocin from
orgasming together,
bonds people.
So I've always thought generally like if
I'm in a period in my life,
arm jerk jerking awful lot,
it's like usually like there's something
imbalanced in there.
Like I don't mean to apply like a sin to
it at all.
I'm just saying like personally it feels
a little dissipative when you're doing
it a lot.
There is this,
I don't know,
that's completely agree.
That's the balance.
But the balance is also like you don't
want to just be horny all the time.
No,
because when you're hunting you make
shitty decisions.
So you like,
yeah,
you'll date someone just for sex.
Yeah.
Well you need to like.
I mean I think that there is something
to be said for figuring out how to deal
with like the,
that kind of energy.
So that's an,
that's an energetic state.
Like if suddenly you get being horny is
an energetic state.
Yeah.
It's energy.
Like if you're really horny and you sit
and like watch the,
the feeling itself,
it's electrical.
You could feel it moving around in your
body.
It like,
it can almost make a twitchy a little
bit.
Like it's like a very potent energetic
state.
So theoretically instead of trying to
get the question would be rather is
there a way to release that energy that
isn't through the tip of my Dick in the
form of DNA?
Is there a way for me to release that
energy in other ways or is the only way
the only valve on that to come?
That's a question.
What do you think?
I think there's this natural buildup
happens.
It makes people more easily aroused,
it makes people more concentrating on
sex and I think that that can put you
out of balance too.
You can be put out of balanced both by
too much masturbation.
You could definitely be put out of
balance by too much desire for sex.
Yeah,
because you just horny show you just
take care of it yourself and you'd be
relieved and then you can think clearer.
You know?
I think the body needs a balance.
Right.
That's why I'm a big proponent of
exercise.
I'm a big proponent of meditation and
mindfulness and just trying to.
I mean it's.
That's all those are toxic words right
now.
Meditation and mindfulness.
Yeah.
They've been thrown around by too many
knuckleheads.
Like there's something about it that
it's like,
oh,
that's kind of a bull shitty word.
You kind of know what I mean.
You're like,
oh,
I'm just all about mindfulness.
Like,
oh,
you're annoying.
That's what you are.
The annoying guy.
I,
I saw a book just yesterday and one of
these boutique stores,
someone had made a star cast at kids but
called the grownups guide to mindfulness
and whoever wrote that fucking book
hates the word mindful.
Definitely has an obnoxious friend who's
into mindfulness because of the book is
just like A.
First of all,
the guy doesn't seem to really
understand what it is in the book.
Like it's a,
he seemed a little confused about the
nature of it,
but uh,
and I remember looking at that and been
like,
oh,
I guess people are getting annoyed with
the word mindfulness now.
Like the pendulum swinging that way.
Yeah.
It's one of those words that people love
to say it sounds good and it makes you
seem like a spiritual person.
So it gets when it gets moved around and
used too much,
like something happens to where it gets
icky.
Yeah.
Because it's like it becomes popular and
then people start using it and then you
see like a bunch of phony guru type
dudes at seminars using it.
What's important here is mindfulness.
Very important that,
you know,
there's like typically unique behaviors,
you know what I mean?
There's,
there's,
especially when it comes to like people
that are full of shit as like a typical
uniqueness.
Like there's just a thing that a lot of
people adopt and it sounds like everyone
else and it's just a way that people do
it.
And uh,
I,
I hope you understand like,
what are you doing?
Why are you doing that?
You're adopting this weird,
funky thing and you know,
I think it's really important that we
practice mindfulness.
It falls into that.
It falls into that even though it's an
excellent practice.
Well,
it's very important,
but people,
you know,
it's called in.
I,
I just,
I now have,
I took on,
for lack of a better word,
I'm working with a actual,
a teacher of the [inaudible] lineage of
Buddhism,
which is Chogyam.
Trungpa is lineage of Buddhism and he's
amazing and he's,
and he's teaching me mindfulness
meditation practice.
This Guy David nichtern.
But um,
how does he deal with masturbation?
What's cool about him is if you asked
him,
he'd,
he would tell you.
I'm sure there's no like,
yeah,
with,
you know,
that he wouldn't be like,
wow,
dad,
you asked me that question,
but I think that probably I don't,
I can't answer for him.
I think it would fall in line with what
you're saying with balance,
you know,
which is that.
It's really like a sort of the concept
with it is the thing that is happening
right now.
Whatever it may be,
you can just,
you know,
apply mindfulness to it.
You could apply like a being in the
moment and being with the thing that's
happening right now.
And so the,
the thing he's teaching me,
I love it so much because it isn't,
we will we or like out there crazy.
It's literally this very simple way that
you meditate with the way that you sit,
which is you sit on a cushion,
you put your hands on your knees in and
you sit back and that he,
the word they use in this Kagyu lineage.
Ford is the warrior pose.
And what that means is that it's a kind
of confidence.
It's the way,
like people who are like confident sit.
So you sit like that when you're
meditating,
you're legs are crossed and you sit in a
chair if you want and you look straight
ahead about eight feet,
nine feet,
and you watch your breath and when you
go into your thoughts,
which happens,
of course you go,
you think thinking and then you go back
to your breath.
That's it.
You say thinking,
you don't say it,
you think it.
Thank.
Thank you.
Thinking just so [inaudible] what?
What's all these.
So like what,
what you start realizing when you start
this practice and full disclosure here,
man,
you know me Joe,
I have problems with discipline and I
have problems with like sticking to
stuff over and over again and working
with this guy has been incredible
because it's actually getting me to,
to do it right.
Uh,
but still I have like I did it today.
I didn't do it yesterday.
I'm just,
I don't want to get out there and some
nonsense that I'm like spending all day
long meditating.
But what you start seeing is when you're
doing it is you realize like,
oh,
there's a cycle happening in my
consciousness.
In my mind,
there's a cycle that's happening in my
life,
which is that I kind of blink into the
moment following the breath and I blink
out of the moment into the thought
realm,
right?
We're like little fireflies wee flicker
into the moment.
We're here now.
We're here,
we're not lost in our thoughts.
We're not thinking about the next thing
we're going to say.
we're going to do.
We're just here in this moment.
And then we're off.
You know,
often running,
like thinking about the bills,
forget about the girl thinking about the
thing,
thinking about that.
And then that leads to another thought
and another thought.
Next thing you know,
you've been thinking for three years
straight,
you know what I mean,
or three minutes or five hours or
whatever,
and then you come back and that's the
cycle.
This is a cycle that happens.
So mindfulness is starting to pay
attention and,
and,
and to that cycle.
But,
and the breathing thing is kind of like
a respiratory mnemonic device,
which is that suddenly what's been
happening to me now is I'll just be like
walking down the street in the notice my
breath.
Oh Shit,
I'm back.
Oh,
I'm here.
I was totally over my head.
Oh,
I'm back.
That was thinking,
you know,
that's all.
It's very,
very,
very simple.
But he's just teaching me the basic
right now.
It does.
I
think it pretty interesting on my own
thinking about my own life and observing
other people's lives.
I've come up with this thing that I
bring up all the time.
The momentum of your past like your,
your,
like so many people as they're going
down the street.
So many people as they're interacting
with people,
they're carrying the momentum of all the
fucked up things that are going on.
Bills that they have to pay and things
that they forgot to do and a career they
never chase.
And a girl,
they never called back.
And the thing that they lied about,
a thing they stole and the reason why
they got fired from work.
And maybe if I call my boss,
I'll get my and all this craziness
you're bringing with you into everything
that is so hard to escape.
It's so hard for people to escape the
momentum of the past.
You know,
people sort of get into this thing of
defining themselves by failures,
by past failures.
And it never just learning from them go
on that fucking loser.
It's a real problem.
It's a real problem with people to be
able to learn from something and to just
look at yourself.
And it's painful to look at yourself.
So everybody wants to pretend that they
didn't do anything wrong right there.
Everybody else is an asshole and that.
Yeah.
And so when you're doing what you're
doing by doing that is you're stunting
your own growth.
You feel like you're protecting yourself
because you're protecting your ego.
You're like,
you know,
I didn't do anything wrong.
Fuck him.
He's the asshole.
But you know,
you could've avoided that.
You know,
you could've done better.
Like everybody has moments like that in
their life and the more you avoid those
and don't take credit for the ones that
you actually fucked up,
the more you actually hurt yourself in
this ironic thing because it seems like
you're protecting yourself.
Know your.
I'm exonerating myself from guilt as
fuck it.
It wasn't me.
Oh,
didn't do it,
but you know you did so in your head,
you're the guy who lies about making
mistakes instead of you're the guy who
mans up to your mistakes and realizes it
was a mistake and then vows to do
better.
Yeah,
man,
that's beautiful.
That's beautiful.
You have to just have to be able to say
you're wrong.
You have to be able to say,
I'm sorry.
You have to be able to,
and you got to be able to look at
yourself like all the time.
Now you've just,
when you fuck up,
because you can avoid some of those fuck
ups.
Just look at yourself critically along
the way,
but we all have to understand that
we're.
We are all in evolving process.
Like I had this conversation with Dennis
Mckenna.
It's a crazy conversation because it's a
ridiculous thing to say,
but he was talking about a Donald Trump
and I was saying,
d,
isn't it possible that he could grow and
learn?
Like why do we give up on people?
Why does a guy get to a certain age and
we say,
oh,
he's 60.
He set in his ways.
He's 70.
He'll never change.
You'll never evolve.
You don't ever say that about a 20 year
old.
You see some asshole who's a 20 year
He said he just needs discipline and
just needs.
Love finds the right pr people in his
life,
right person to love.
He'll be okay.
He's gonna mature and eventually he's
going to be a solid man,
but you get to a certain age.
We just give up on you just like you're
still alive,
but you've passed the cycle that I
usually people to be ready to sort of
interact as valuable creative,
loving members of society.
Pass that by.
You're still thinking about yourself.
Only deepen your sixties.
This is stupid shit.
This is shit you're supposed to do when
you're 17.
By the time you're 70,
you're supposed to be going,
oh my God,
I don't have much time left.
Oh my God,
what have I done while I'm here?
What do.
What is it important?
What do I feel the best about?
I feel the best about love and
companionship and friendship and real
warmth and interaction between people
that you care about.
This money thing,
man,
this is not.
You can't keep chasing this.
Can't keep chasing power.
Can't keep chasing money.
You're gonna.
Reach a point where it's not going to
matter because you're going to die,
so you really want to be that guy from
the bumper sticker.
He who dies with the most toys wins
because this is literally what you're
working towards.
You're working towards a joke.
Yeah.
Well I will let.
Can I.
One thing I would add to that is that,
so what you're saying here,
and you're.
You're right man,
but the one thing I think I disagree
with you on is that you're creating a
situation where that's it.
You die and that's it.
The momentum smack the momentum goes
into a black hole.
It's gone.
Like the momentum has been like as
disintegrates vanishes,
that momentum,
right?
But the way I've been taught is that
actually that momentum keeps going.
That momentum doesn't just stop because
your body stops,
right?
So that momentum keeps going and in fact
the,
what's really beautiful is like.
And it's good that you call it momentum.
That's exactly what it is,
what it feels like with me.
It's a tendency,
we have a tendency towards a certain
thing.
We have proclivities and tendencies and
habituation and if you just kind of
like,
if you put you in me in a room and put a
bunch of different objects on the floor,
right,
you're gonna go toward something and I'm
going to go towards something else,
right.
You know,
if there's fucking vr goggles and a in
a,
in a God damn bad ass,
like some kind of like bad ass compound
bow manufactured it fucking Darpa.
You know what I mean?
And there's vr goggles manufactured by
Darpa.
I don't know,
I'm going for the VR goggles.
You're probably going to go for the
cross or the boat,
right?
So we have proclivities.
We have.
That's the momentum,
right?
That is one way you can understand what
Karma is,
right?
So that's the momentum.
That's the moment.
So that thing that you've got right now,
when you begin to really look at it and
think about it,
you could ask yourself,
when did this start?
This momentum,
right?
When did this,
these proclivities and tendencies and
things that I'm being like sort of
pushed towards.
When did they start in?
A lot of it is your parents taught you
certain things,
but
well,
let's talk about a super common one
that's horrible.
Cigarettes you,
you got cooked by that bug.
Are He got hooked by that bug?
Red Band still hooked.
Joey Diaz kicked it.
You know that's a.
that's a really,
really,
really common one.
Man.
That's sorta defines people on that guy
who I'm
going to walk into this store and even
though I know these things cause cancer,
I'm going to buy a pack.
I'm gonna go outside and I can't wait to
light it up.
I'm just not even thinking about that
right now,
man.
I'm trying to relax.
And you get that thing in your mouth.
There you go.
And you take that drag and you feel that
cancer causing chemical rush.
Yup.
And you're like,
I'll take it,
I'm alright today.
No cancer.
You take a big deep breath in and blow
it out.
And you look at the other fellow cancer
dodgers and they're just looking at Jill
and smoking together and everybody just
really good at dodging cancer.
So,
you know,
another one way you could actually say
it is like every time you do that you're
planting a seed.
So every time you smoke a cigarette,
you could imagine that you have this
field right in the field is your health.
And in that field,
anytime you like exercise or do
something,
you know,
decide instead of eating the fucking ice
cream you're going to eat.
The seaweed chips are like,
anytime you do that,
you could just imagine obviously it's
not the way it works exactly.
But you could think I'm planting a seed
in this field,
right?
So if I keep planning certain types of
seeds and any type of field and I
cultivate those seeds,
they're going to grow into something,
right?
That's Karma.
So what,
when,
when you know for a person,
when the cancer comes,
when the muscles come,
when the failure comes,
when the success comes,
if you look at that moment,
you realized this is actually the
flowering of a thing that's been growing
for a very long time inside of me or in
the world or in time.
So that's the idea people already have
within them planted.
All of these seeds haven't,
haven't been expressed yet into time
because they're still inside of them.
Like the dude with the like imagine a
guy with the guy who shot the guy
because he had road rage.
You know,
that guy for years had a really bad
anger disorder and he knew it.
He would look.
He would think at times in this very
moment,
I get really angry all the time.
I don't know if this is normal,
right?
A lot of those people were beaten when
they were kids.
That's it,
dude.
Yeah.
Common Super Common Trauma.
So yeah man,
that's like cigarette smoking.
Any kind of behavior that like is risky
or over time produces some kind of
negative result.
It's just planting seeds.
You know,
and so the momentum you're experiencing
right now is the sum total of all those
fucking seeds that you planted and that
were planted inside of you over the
course of your life.
That's what you're,
you are,
you're like a walking field of Karma at
varying stages of growth,
growing varying types of vegetation and
some are good and some are bad,
but it's like that's what you are right
now.
And what's beautiful about that is that
means that you can start cultivating
field.
You know,
you don't have to just like let it grow
wild and,
and pretend every time you smoke a
cigarette or do some stupid shit,
you're like an unconscious farmer.
Oh my God,
what?
I'm drinking and driving again,
but I got to get home.
Oh Shit.
Oh my God.
The Dui plant grew again in the field.
I wonder why that thing keeps growing in
my field.
You keep fucking drinking and driving,
dude.
The Dui play out.
Yeah.
Oh God.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You can cultivate it.
That's what's beautiful about it.
You know,
you can cultivate the field.
You don't have to let it just have
fucking weird random weeds spring up
though when a patch or to have some
weeds because those are fun.
Imagine spending that tobacco money and
spending that money thinking about all
that cancer,
spending all that money.
God just buying a big castle.
What all that cancer money.
Castle cancer.
Hey,
the people want it.
They want it.
Yet in this country,
you've got the freedom to buy whatever
you want.
Well,
yeah,
right.
I mean it's a person's choice,
but.
But to get back to what you were just
saying,
the ethics of the fucking day.
How about this?
How many people who run big tobacco own
stock in companies that make
chemotherapy drugs?
There is a big question like how many of
those people in their portfolio that
they barely know about,
they're like,
well,
you know,
like a really big investment these days
is a k gene therapy for cancer.
Really
cancer out of hand these days.
Huh?
Interesting.
I wonder what could be going wrong.
The problem with cigarettes is that
they're addictive.
Will just kill you.
Yeah,
but that they're addictive.
Like I,
I've smoked a cigarette before and it
gives you a head rush.
Wasn't like a nice little weird rush.
It's.
And also the,
the other problem is nicotine is a
madison and,
and it has like some health benefits if
used in the right way.
And also it's a nootropic so yeah,
it's not,
it's not just like it gives you a rush.
It's like it's it,
it's a little bit.
Steven King said that was one of the
most difficult things when he quit
smoking was not having one way.
Right?
That's right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Because you,
because that's the nature of addiction.
It's like Kudzu dies,
did trees.
It wraps around your favorite thing in
life and tricks you ended Kudzu.
Kudzu is a plant that was introduced
from Japan and I think from Japan into
the south and it's just a growing.
We vine that when it wraps around trees
and it covers them up completely so the
trees can't get any sun and the trees
just die.
Yeah.
It wasn't native to the United States,
so sometimes,
I don't know,
maybe they took care of Gutsy,
but when I was a kid you would drive by
these beautiful forests that were where
the trees were just covered in.
Fucking cuts it.
Yeah.
Like,
yeah,
that's crazy.
It's like they got eaten other plant.
That's right,
man.
And those trees are dying.
They can't get the sun.
The.
Oh my God.
It's insane.
And that's a great metaphor for
addiction or for [inaudible] is a
perfect metaphor.
Yeah.
My God.
That's insane.
How did I not know about this?
It's definitely seems like something
you'd know about.
Look,
it looks like they're alive.
It looks like people do.
There's just too much to know.
There's too much cool shit.
Shit out there.
Too much.
Look at that.
Felt.
Go to the one above that.
Above that.
Above that one,
right above that.
Yeah.
That one.
Look at that.
Yeah,
the green.
That is.
That's insane.
Dude.
That does something weird.
Your brain beautiful.
It's like,
it makes you feel like you're like
you're on a drug.
Like if you were standing there and it
was that green and that like vibrant,
you'd be like,
oh my God.
Yup.
Yeah,
you would.
It would feel so good when you ever see
anything that looks like that.
I say,
let those fuckers take over.
Let do,
take over trees.
Can't fight off the Kudzu.
They don't deserve to live.
You have to fucking evolve.
These cuts were cooler.
They're offering your cooler look,
but he's like,
hey,
you want to look at your boring ass
fucking gray bar?
Bullshit leaves on the ground or how
about we just take over everything?
What the fuck are we cover?
The floor carpet?
Yeah,
we covered the floor and the hillsides
and all the trees.
Everything Green is.
Fuck.
Okay.
Well what kind of green like flow green
man,
like vibrant flow green will you.
If you smoke weed there,
you're going to trip balls.
Yeah.
Look at that.
What is that?
A covered it.
Statue is at a golf statue.
That's just this telephone pole light
pole that it seems like so good.
Have sculpted that a little bit maybe.
Or maybe it's just really covering a
light pole.
Yeah,
yeah man,
there you go.
So that,
that that's like a really funny thing
that like,
like alcoholics,
they'll get their alcoholism wound up
and their social life or like their
creativity,
their creative cycle,
so they will think like,
fuck man,
without the booze,
I don't think I'm going to be able to
write as well or you know,
whatever it is.
It mostly,
it's just people who have this a really
smart way to avoid getting healthier or,
or the learning curve associated with
getting healthier and it's a really
intelligent trick to play on yourself,
which is,
do imagine that,
you know,
whatever it may be that's currently out
of balance in your life.
If you remove that,
you're not going to be able to be as
good as person.
You know?
There's a lot of alcoholics out there
who are performers who think,
oh,
if I don't drink,
I got to have a beer on stage man or
early.
Where it gets hard core is when it's
like actually fucking wrapped up in the
art publicly.
Like,
I don't know if you're aware of this
rapper who died named Lil peep,
you know,
about little peep I heard about him.
Yeah.
And one of his videos that just shows
like the,
the floor of his car,
the f just pill bottles scattered
everywhere.
Right.
So like part of the identity,
he,
he was projecting into the world
involved like the Romanticization of
addiction to pharmaceutical medications.
Right.
And so that's where it gets real.
Or like big comics when all their jokes
are about being fat and if they.
So they,
they don't only have to like,
worry about like,
you know,
being fat,
they have to worry about if I got
healthy,
I don't know if my jokes are gonna work
anymore.
So you know what I mean?
It's like that's,
that's how insidious it can get,
you know?
Yeah.
That's great.
Good one.
That one does creep in.
I actually heard Kevin James,
I heard someone say that to him,
you lose weight,
you're losing roles.
God.
Someone just told me,
it's like you either need to lose 15
pounds or gain 15 pounds if you want to
get in the movie.
I don't remember he said that,
but it's like,
yeah,
it's like you know,
you,
you're,
you become this character or something
like that in the next thing you know,
you're fucking addiction is just riding
you around like a horse whispering in
your ear without me will know where to
go and now you're fucked.
You're fucked.
Yeah.
I'm your comfort blanket.
Like you're all alone.
When you're drinking alone in your hotel
room.
Woo.
Dark.
That's dark.
But then when you get into it too,
when you're not just drinking alone,
but you're like telling stories to
yourself,
celebrating it.
You're pretending.
Anytime you find yourself pretending
you're fucking hunter.
S Thompson,
baby,
get a cigarette holder unless you're
writing like him.
You ain't hunter s Thompson.
All right.
You're having fun.
No doubt.
But I know in my life like the Times
where I've been like,
it's of like a hunter,
s Thompson.
It's like,
dude,
you need to go to bed.
Yeah.
Like stop.
You're like you,
you,
you're,
you're tricking yourself.
Now you know,
that's.
I'll just don't trick yourself.
By the way,
if you want to be a self destructive
alcoholic,
drug addict,
whatever it is,
be that thing,
but don't fool yourself into thinking
that's not what you're doing.
It's romantic.
Yeah.
Don't like as your plummeting towards
splattering all over the fucking ground.
Pretend that you're flying towards the
earth.
Well,
maybe you could.
Maybe that's actually a cool way to tie.
That's a good way to think
right before impact.
Maybe that's the water tower.
God did.
Yeah.
Dude.
Maybe so
in who knows what you see when you do
eight days of Iowasca who know what you
see?
That seems like eight days of any potent
psychedelic.
I've never done that.
I've never done more than one day in a
row.
I've done one day in a row,
take a break,
maybe a little pot the next day,
and then I don't do anything for like
months.
That's how I've always done it.
I've never done like a big session
followed by big session.
Yeah.
I know.
We can only speculate.
I don't know exactly what that would be
like.
I mean,
I can imagine.
I couldn't imagine.
Dude,
I had this crazy idea,
crazy idea.
Now this is a lens,
I don't know if it's true or not,
but obviously it's probably not true,
but I got this crazy idea that like,
and again,
like this with you,
I could just say this and I don't have
to preface it,
but since people isn't your podcasts,
I have to preface it by saying I do not
believe this.
I'm not going insane,
but this is a fun thing to think about.
You know,
it's okay to imagine shit in your mind.
It's okay.
Like you can imagine stuff.
But.
So I was thinking like inspiration,
right?
Specifically I was thinking like Jr
Tolkien when you read Lord of the Rings,
it's like that guy went over there that
writing is so beautiful and so perfect.
And so like interdimensional extra
dimension old.
It's fucking old book and it's
beautiful.
His writing.
Yeah.
I was thinking,
Oh that guy token that inspiration is
outflow from the DMT realm into this
dimension through the,
um,
through the processor of his meat
computer.
And this is like a kind of drip coming
out of a dam.
The dam is something that's been
constructed by power structures who want
to keep that realm out of here.
Right?
And so over there you get usually a kind
of message,
right?
And the message is usually something
along the lines of,
we need to love each other.
We can love each other here.
There's something more important than
money,
uh,
to really be very reductive about it,
but some version of that story that
usually involves some kind of desire to
no longer harm people or to reduce
suffering or to be a better person or
however you want to put it.
Right?
So there's a dam that's been built and
the dam is built by the people who scan
your pis for Lsd.
It's people who have created an
intentional legal obstruction between
one realm and the other,
which is the realm mechanical hyperspace
in the realm that we're currently
existing in,
which is where there's a lot of
scientific materialism where people only
believe that there is only matter here.
There's only matter.
That's it.
There's nothing else.
No spirit,
no soul,
right gatekeepers.
The gatekeepers I,
I've been,
I used to think of them as gatekeepers.
Now I think of them as dam builders,
builders,
and what happens is from time to time,
a big crack in the dam opens up,
right?
That's when someone like fucking Martin
Luther King appears in his standing in
front of so many people telling them.
I think that we're all the same,
is what I think.
I think we're all the same and he's
doing it in this very charismatic,
beautiful way,
right?
That's a big fucking crack in the dam
because over on this side of things,
they don't want us to be all the same.
They want us to be separated by a lot of
different fucking things.
They don't want us to be all the same
over here.
So the cracks in the dam opened up and
the big cracks,
Bam.
The little cracks.
They're like the good art,
the good poetry,
the great movies,
the good inspiration,
and now what's happening because of the
fucking Internet is,
Oh,
these fucking cracks in the dam or
opening up.
They can't seal them up anymore.
It's like you can't see all the fucking
damn anymore in the singularity that
Mckenna was talking about the
apocalypse,
which actually means lifting of the
veil.
What did that is,
is when the dam reaches a point where
the structural integrity has been
permanently compromised in the DMT
realm,
flows into this dimension in the form of
some kind of technology that either
unifies all of us are like rips a hole
literally into whatever that membrane is
that separates us from the infinite,
and that is what for whatever reason,
over in this dimension,
people have been trying to stop so
because it impedes progress in terms of
like making money.
We're building businesses.
You can't be building businesses if
people were doing lsd on their brakes.
I don't think that's true.
I think you could run a wonderful
business.
No,
no,
no.
They're going to come back and they're
not going to be concerned with
productivity.
Well,
they're not going to be.
No,
no,
no.
If we get a group of people together and
start building something amazing,
not for money.
Oh No.
I'm just being facetious.
Certainly can be done.
I'm,
I'm arguing with the devil's advocate.
What?
Okay.
Let me play the devil.
Okay,
nice to meet you.
Finally,
can I have my soul back?
No.
Dammit.
This whole thing of you exploring hyper
dimensional space and all that stuff,
all that does is make you stupider and
you show up at work and you,
you're less disciplined and you're not
interested in getting the job done.
Okay.
This company is built on teamwork.
Okay?
And it's built on everyone pulling their
weight.
Now,
if you're off fucking off in hyperspace
from Friday night to Sunday morning and
you barely get six hours sleep over the
weekend and you show up Monday,
I'm going to test your pis.
Okay?
Yeah,
and if I find silicide been in there or
anything else fucking squirrely.
Do you mind if I show you David Nuts?
Professor David Nutt,
study on the landsat about the dangers
of the variety of drugs I,
I'd like I'm talking to the devil here.
Do
you mind if I show you this?
Because if you notice sir,
on this chart,
they again published in the landsat is
peer reviewed.
This is a very important study,
Professor David Knight,
of course,
has since been disbarred and somewhere
and accrued some kind of horrible
punishment for being an advocate for
psychedelics.
But anyway,
sir,
forgive me,
but if you'll,
you'll notice on this chart,
psilocybin is considered the least
harmful of mind.
All three candidates
interested in harmful.
Sir.
I'm interested in productivity.
I want this place to run fast.
We're in competition and we're losing
jobs overseas.
Do you know they're going to start to
make Harley motherfucking Davidson
motorcycles in Thailand?
Yes sir.
Yeah.
What kind of Shit is that?
I know it's a goddamn American bike and
they're making it over in fucking Asia.
Why?
Because the people in the factory over
here didn't kick ass.
Okay.
They're over in the fucking park taking
their magic mushrooms and trip and balls
when they should be thinking about how
they keep this company active.
This company feeds and houses 150
families.
You understand that?
Yes.
Or how it's 100.
Are you happy now?
You still want to fucking raise serve
before I forget,
I picked up your prescription for
oxycodone,
Oxycontin fucker.
I'll take it on their oxygen.
Bullshit.
Yeah.
Your extra postage.
You're on adderall.
You're methamphetamine.
Yeah.
One hundred percent.
So yeah.
Right.
So.
So D'evelyn,
devil lab.
So.
Right.
So the answer to it is that I'm talking
to you.
Oh,
well here's the problem sir.
You don't realize this,
but you're kind of a low level priest in
a,
in a religion that is spread far and
wide and in this religion it's not
really the,
the,
the money that you're interested in as
much as it is the power because you have
become a servant of a being called the
demiurge,
which is essentially attempting to
create as sort of authoritarian
hierarchy in this particular dimension
that's been separated from another place
known as the galactic.
You can call it whatever the fuck you
want,
but it's the aliens.
It's a galactic civilization that is
about to pour into this civilization and
so it really doesn't matter what you do
because within the next 20 or 30 years
through technology and through the
unification of people because of the
fact that technology,
you're gonna either come to our site or
go completely insane.
Okay.
The counter to that of course is the
only way you're gonna get there.
You fucking lazy hippies because if we
make you go to work and we get shit done
and you buy things and you keep this
fucking country's economy healthy that
way.
The technology innovators,
that way we make the hyperspace gateway.
You Lazy fucking hippies tripping balls
on your lawn furniture.
You're not creating shit.
Okay.
You show up for work on time.
You get the job done.
Eventually we'll get our portal.
Well,
it sounds okay.
Can I address something you just said
Satan?
Yes.
On time.
Now this is a very funny term.
Thank God I'm reading David grave the.
Here's a great term on time.
Right?
So like boss,
the.
The problem is that like the thing
you're doing with time are being on
time.
That's a relatively new imposition into
society and it started with clock
towers.
During the industrial revolution,
they'd put clock towers up so the people
always knew what time it was,
so they wouldn't be late for going to
work in a.
In a factory.
You see,
there was a time when people weren't
like obsessed with their fucking watch
because the idea that you could sell
time,
here's what it is,
sir.
You think you and I have entered into a
contract where for some ridiculous
reason I've agreed to sell you eight
hours of time.
My time per day.
It's essentially a form of slavery.
It's a kind of like slavery,
except I get to go free for a certain
amount of hours per week into servitude.
Yeah,
we can call it that with like less of
the power.
I can leave anytime I want indentured
servants.
I don't think they could because they
were kind of trapped until they paid a
certain.
Certain jobs are contract will,
you could quit most jobs.
I mean that's kind of the
rationalization that people use is
they're like,
you can leave anytime you want bud in
anytime you want.
The hard jobs are those jobs where
people work for salary and their time is
just whatever the project takes.
Like.
Do you ever talk to so many worse on
video games?
Right now I've.
I've met very few people.
I mean,
I met a few,
but it's like they don't work in the big
companies do the hours that they put in
before a video game is released is
insane.
Right?
A lot of them just sleep in the offices
to work in 16 hours a day.
Just coding.
They're all living on top of each other.
A brutal,
brutal,
brutal.
Yeah.
Brutal.
And,
and
this is sounding job.
You're asking for someone's whole life.
That's right.
You're asking for the whole life.
You occasionally can get away from me
and go camping.
You occasionally get away from me.
Have a picnic with your family.
You wish.
Usually you can get away,
but for many,
many months I want you all the time.
I just want you there all the time.
And in exchange I'll give you some
money.
So like
conceptually I don't think that this is
like a terrible situation as long as the
person is really into what they're
doing.
Right?
And then what we have is just kind of
like a,
um,
I guess you could say what a capitalist
commune or I don't know what you'd call
it.
It's like a group of people commuting
together as seeking to like extract
money from the universe,
but also like,
you know what comes to mind?
Sorry,
anyone from blizzard who's listening you
like doesn't like your job there,
but I got to.
I went to on this tour of blizzard and
they fucking every company that makes
video games,
they make the
best video games outside of like the
only game I notch up with it right now
I'm in the god of war,
so fucking good.
But it looks pretty bad ass.
It is amazing.
It is amazing dude.
It's the first triple a game I've liked
in so long.
What's a aaa?
Is it?
It's called AAA.
Aaa.
It's a really expensive game to make.
It's like,
it's like a hardcore big time.
Pull up a video.
God,
it's so graphics are pretty fucking
incredible,
dude.
Dude.
It's beautiful.
Don't get me.
Get fucked.
That alien damn bullshit.
God award is like.
It's so good man.
And like I'm stuck in it.
Right?
Put on the HTC Vive today.
The new one that we.
You didn't get into a game yet.
There's some games in it where you're
just like,
Whoa,
I see where this is going and I saw that
from yours from,
but yours was when I was over at your
place.
What was that?
Two or three years ago,
two years ago.
Look how good the good that is.
He can see like the dirt on his hands.
It's like you're watching an episode of
Viking Dude.
It's really good and it's.
And it's like bitch ass fucking thing
freezing up again.
Here it goes.
So this is actual gameplay.
See Why is this fucking game play?
Dude?
That's gameplay.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
it's incredible.
It's amazing.
She's so hot.
Very hot.
I think you could hang out with the
trick was like cut people's heads off a
sorts.
Yes,
absolutely.
Look at her,
look at him rather her fucking bad dude.
What's great about this game is not just
like the graphics which are incredible
or the fight mechanics,
which are also incredible,
but the fucking story is really good and
the acting is really good and like the
relationships between characters are
really intense.
This game will make you like tear up
man.
Like it's like fucking,
we should see what he just did.
Chop that dude and half with an ax.
Holy Fuck Up.
Is this got smashed by a smashed.
He gets smashed a lot,
but he's created us.
The God of war.
He doesn't give a fuck.
Does not give a fuck man.
That's incredible.
Wouldn't even show much more of this.
It's spoilers.
I don't want anybody to see any of the
characters or to know what's happening
because it's that good.
Like it's such a good game.
Most Games,
the way I've played video games is I try
to rush through it for some reason,
which is really dumb to be like,
oh,
I got to win this thing,
this one you want to hang out,
look around,
see the landscape.
And like you get really into it.
It's a glorious game.
But you know that to get back to where
you're talking about it.
Blizzard,
uh,
one,
one of the people working there told me,
we like building world of warcraft
because we liked playing world of
warcraft.
We've created a dimension we want to be
inside of like we enjoy it,
they love it.
And,
and that's why the game is so good
because it's being made by people who
enjoy playing the game.
So I don't know how many hours they work
at blizzard.
I imagine it's,
it can be pretty brutal schedule,
but in anything you do,
even things you love I know become
grueling,
but I think that example of a company
versus a company where you're like
either doing something that you don't
even need to be there to do or no
comparison,
no comparison.
I mean it might be massive hours a day,
but I bet you're having a great time a
lot of the time and the actual results
and saying,
you know,
I was friends with a lot of those guys
from id software back in the quick two
days and played quake three.
I got to play quake three before it ever
came up with you.
We are trying.
That's Dallas Clif.
No,
Clif Eeb.
He's soft software as doom and quake.
Cliff Eby is unreal.
Oh No,
I was with you and cliff.
He began to her.
I didn't see the quake two as well.
Both amazing.
But we.
Yeah,
we got to see unreal tournament when
they were putting that together and they
were putting together this new engine
that will not being used in a bunch of
different games afterwards,
but it was fucking crazy.
We get to see the graphics like as
they're designing things and same thing
with the quakes studios,
but those guys all were crazy gamer so
they would get land parties and sync all
we played at the ID software.
We got to play death matches between
everybody in the studio.
It was awesome to play quake with the
guys who made quake.
Fucking cool,
funny shit.
I've fucking cool man.
And you know,
I mean what they did was if you've never
played one of those games before,
the three dimensional games,
when you're running down,
you hear things over here behind you and
you like you,
you know,
you could turn around and sneak around
corners and people are chasing around
the map and sometimes you could walk and
it doesn't make any noise or you could
run and you can hear the footsteps.
Fucking cool as fuck.
It's the crazy.
This is so adrenaline packed when you're
playing this game.
So these guys,
I'm so terrified.
We're putting a land in here in the next
couple of weeks.
Now you are.
Oh,
we're going to.
You and I were going to have some fun.
Well,
no,
we're not because you're going to be me
at fucking quake.
I suck at shooter's.
Dude.
Played in forever please and played for
ever.
I'll probably be terrible for the first
16 hours if I like.
Had a shrink ray and shrunk you like
into like an eight year old.
You would still beat me at shooters.
I suck at fucking shooters,
man.
I was your thing.
What do you like?
You liked those a roleplay say at dude,
because you're going to make fun of me.
I won't do it on.
I like hearthstone.
Man.
Was that.
I don't even know what it is.
Fucking fell for it.
He didn't fall for it.
I'm being sincere.
I don't know what it is in mine.
Fantasy card game.
It's like a furry thing like furries.
I love comedians seminar because it's
like I knew you were going to insult me.
I just didn't know
how and like it's way the way you did.
It was way worse than I expected.
Thank you.
Pretend to be a Fox,
right?
Fox Kin.
Are you?
Other than you,
other kids get a kick out of it.
Do you ever do it in your footie
pajamas?
Like a little bunny rabbit tail on
either the woods and I'm a rabid dog.
Fuck man.
I've got to be clever to get away from
the joint.
Say,
let me tell you something.
It's a wonderful fucking game with and
it's deep and it's got a lot of strategy
and I and I and I love playing it,
man.
I really do.
I'm not good at anymore.
I went through a period of being good.
I haven't played it in awhile because
I've been playing God of war,
but Oh,
look at this.
Is this it?
Yeah.
This looks like death.
What is happening?
What is happening here?
Let's see your cards.
Yeah,
they're cards.
You basically like the.
I'm not going to explain the rules.
A hearthstone on your show dude,
but those don't.
Great Games is killing me.
It's a great.
It's a great,
very fun,
very enjoyable game,
good game for nine year old girls.
That's what it looks like.
Get it for my kid and I'm just thinking
like,
ah,
to do is say star craft or I could ally,
but I knew I had to tell you the truth,
but I knew you were addicted that
you got a real problem with that for
while you and I met each other in our
video game.
Addictive tendency.
We're both like,
yeah,
gotTa be careful.
But Dude,
you know this.
This is something I was thinking I
wanted to bring up during the podcast.
Man.
It's like when we first started hanging
out and you told me something I've never
gotten in.
It's from the book of five rings by Mia
Motto Musashi and you mentioned
something from that book which is that
learn one thing and you will know how to
do a lot of other stuff.
Right?
So he would,
uh,
apparently he would,
um,
he was a Samurai and so he recommended
for Samurai not just to learn the sword,
but to learn poetry,
learn how to paint,
learn how to do this step.
Because in the metta process of
learning,
you learn,
you like you,
there's something in there that like
fits onto all forms of learning.
Right?
Well,
you don't want to be too hard,
but you don't want to be too soft.
You want to be a balance right in,
in a balance,
you must.
You have to be artistic and destructive.
You have to be loving and hating.
You know,
he,
he played games with his opponents like
he didn't just fight.
No,
billy,
he was an asshole.
He would show up hours late for duals
and make the guy wait.
Oh,
say knew the guy would be freaking out.
He would show up sometimes with wooden
swords instead of metal swords to fuck
with their heads.
One time he whittled a sword out of an
or of the boat that he,
he rode over to the beach where you're
supposed to have the sword fight.
Showed up hours late.
Fuck Dude.
Up with an or.
Yeah,
he would,
he would play games with people.
I knew that there was psychological
warfare in him showing up late.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
And do you remember the first sentence
of the book?
I do not.
I remember the quote that you just were
talking about because I say it all the
time.
It's like the reason why I have this
tattoo on my arm.
This is Musashi,
you know,
it's,
once you understand the way broadly or
once you know the way broadly,
you will see it in all things that.
Yeah.
So,
so which is also a as above.
So below it's another way of saying that
it's like,
it's.
So it's the concept that uh,
if I practice some things.
Yeah.
For example,
like right now,
like I'm learning how to do modular
synthesis.
Like at modular sense,
they're bad ass.
It's like for making music,
right?
I'm 44.
I'm not like thinking to myself like,
man,
one day I'm going to be fucking based
factor.
I'm not going to get,
you know what I mean?
I don't,
I don't leave.
I'll perform live with them ever.
But I'm,
I,
I got sucked into it and now I'm taking
it seriously.
So I'm learning how to do it for real.
Like,
and then that pulls you into like music
theory,
right?
So now you start looking at,
well what is this song and why does this
song is a song set up like it is and
what her notes and what's a tone,
right?
What's an Oscillator,
what are these things?
And then like from that you get pulled
into like pythagoras and then suddenly
you're like reading like shit by
Pythagoras who like had another great
quote which is do not take the roads
traveled by the public is pretty
awesome,
which means isn't that bad ass?
But um,
but anyway,
the point is like,
because I've been studying like the
modular synthesizer now when I sit down
and play guitar,
like I'm a little better at it.
But then where it gets fucking weird is
when I sit down and play like God a war.
I'm a little better at that too.
And then like when I'm thinking about
cutting tomatoes,
for example,
something really basic and the pressure
I'm exerting to cut the tomato versus
the sharpness of the knife.
I think about music and I think about,
Whoa,
in a weird way,
my knife is like a,
this is,
you won't know what this is.
Maybe like my knife is like a CV gate,
which is like if you have a tone,
like a gate might be an on and off,
like a switch that makes the tango will,
will,
will blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah.
Right.
So suddenly the shit you're learning
from like.
And by the way,
synth nerds out there.
I don't know what I just fucking said.
I fucked it up.
I'm sorry I'm learning but,
but,
but the,
the,
what I'm saying is it's like what he was
saying,
what he was teaching is so powerful,
which is like what?
You don't just get good at one thing it
into other shit and your wife to sure.
That is an incredible thing for me to
realize man.
It's been pretty intense because like,
you know,
when you like what you were saying,
for if you're a 20 year old,
you know,
people expect you to be learning
something,
this or that.
But when you're in your forties,
you know,
you can trick yourself into thinking
like,
I don't need to learn how to do anything
anymore.
And then you're basically like turning
down all the lights in your life because
when you start working on something,
even this is what I was going to ask
you,
and maybe even video games.
Oh,
for sure.
Video Games,
do we dismiss them because they were
thought of as frivolous exercises and we
embrace chess and go and all that.
And even poker because we know that it's
an intellectual pursuit or real poker
players are all super fucking smart
guys.
The guys that were really good at it.
Um,
I think that we do that with video games
because at one point in time they were
just pong and then they were mario
brothers and they were silliness and
fun.
You get the mushroom and have a good
time and PAC man and all that shed.
But now when you see God at war,
you're like,
okay,
well clearly your brain is firing on all
cylinders.
When you're doing that.
You're swinging that acts and switch
into this sphere and doing this.
And jumping there and chopping this
student half and getting away from the
guy with the fucking flying logs thrown
at you.
That's your brain.
Your brain's firing left and right.
The idea that this is totally useless
seems stupid.
Yeah.
So I think that that potentially through
anything,
the problem with video games is you can
play them and actually not get better at
them because you just like are slashing
and pressing buttons and Shit.
Like you have to folk you can focus.
But I think when focus,
when your attention and focus gets put
on improving anything,
like I theoretically,
I imagine if you just started working on
drawing a circle or drawing a perfect
circle and just spent day after day
working on that pursuit sounds insane.
Like you'd look crazy,
dear friends for potentially other shit
in your life.
You'd start improving at to your mind
gets a little sharper maybe.
Maybe it's just some kind of neuro
or something.
I Dunno,
it's exercise.
It's an exercise for your mind for sure.
Your brain is very,
very active when you're playing a video
game.
You know,
I,
I know what I would play,
quake,
my hands would get so sweaty that I
would put antiperspirant on my hands.
I would spray antiperspirant all over my
hands and then I would blow on them to
keep them from getting so sweaty because
my fingers would barely.
They would slip around over the
keyboard.
I leave puddles and keys.
My mouse would get soaking wet.
My it wouldn't be dripping over the
mouse pad and the ball would get stuck.
Then eventually became a laser beam,
laser tracking first suck.
Then it got way better for us was like
you wanted that ball.
He wanted to feel that the ball,
the mouse because you got that tactile
sensation,
but then it got to a point where these
laser ones were so much more accurate
and they never fuck up.
They just became better.
That shit has always been like really
odd to me.
When you look at a gaming mouse and it
says how precise it is under the DPIS
DPI.
I remember razer mouse had one that was
2000 DPI,
the Mamba and it was crazy.
You play with the thing and be like,
Jesus Christ,
it was so fast.
It was an odd shape like it was a duck
foot.
Do you remember that?
Yeah.
Stay away to the ones.
Now you.
There's a button on it.
You can switch mid game depending on
what you're doing or what you need.
You can set up your DPI from uptake.
W 8,000,
10,000,
2000 down to 200.
100.
Wonder why we made it slower.
Slower.
There's some games like you,
you don't need to be moving that much.
Might be a sniper,
so you need very small adjustments and
you can make big moves with your hands
and have still a small adjustment.
Yeah.
Some guys,
when the adrenaline would kick in,
they would like a slow mouse speed and a
big mouse pad and they moved
pat around like that and they felt more
precise that way than they were with a
small pat and a high speed because some
guys used to like do little wrist flicks
were like super high speed and you would
try their mouse.
He'd be like,
hey man,
can I try your setback?
Because everybody set was different and
I would try their setup of like,
Jesus,
how do you even concentrate?
This is crazy.
It's you're moving so fast.
They would have their speeches and they
would.
Our acceleration mouse accelerations.
Yeah.
So if you move faster,
it actually goes faster.
Almost like you're throwing a whip.
Yeah,
I know dude.
You need that in starcraft.
Like you're doing that too.
Oh absolutely.
Yeah.
That's a very important.
Getting your mouse set at the right
speed and then you get used to that
speed.
So if your mouse is fucked up,
you're definitely gonna like you're
gonna make bad decisions.
But I never got like I got.
Okay.
It star craft.
I think I got up to like,
oh no,
maybe silver league or something like
that.
What does that mean?
So if you were interested,
it's not a big deal.
Would you have a purple belt belt after
white belt?
Blue.
What's the one after that?
Purple.
It's probably blue blue belt because
bronze league is where I stayed for
ever.
That's the white belt stage.
Yeah,
mercilessly getting my fucking ass
handed to me in bronze league.
And then like finally I figured it out a
little bit and for I popped into the
silver league and then you want to go
back to the fucking bronze league
because once you get to the silver lake,
you can't do a fucking early game
painting rush.
You can't like,
can't do that.
Fuck no,
you can't do any of that shit.
And when you try it,
when you try it,
they're gonna like they're gonna make
fun.
You know they're going to tie it to you
like no.
But they're also going to be like,
what?
Like,
what are you doing?
You fucking newb fuck you.
Why are you doing that?
Shit,
I wanted a real game.
You're going to do something like early
game failing.
Rushed against my.
You don't want people to get super mad
when they're fucking connection with
timeout.
And they would be stuck in the game and
you'd fuck them up.
Stuck.
Frozen.
Oh yeah.
Just light them up.
You know like
sometimes you do you use like your
smallest gun and just slowly pick away
their house.
Purell Po,
Po,
po.
You Punch him.
When we were in the old quake games,
you could punch dudes.
Yeah,
yeah.
There was some video that popped up at
that new game fortnight.
Everybody's playing and it's like it was
on Undergrad.
I was like the worst fortnight player
ever because it's someone who clearly
got up to go get chips or maybe they
and,
and the dude's like shooting at them and
can't hit like a still person.
Yeah,
man games are bad ass these days.
Man.
I really love him,
but I do like think to myself,
I still am probably just because I'm
like an older person.
I do think there's like a hierarchy of
like what's good to do and I think it's
bad for me.
It's bad.
I like learning music right now.
I like sitting down picking some basic
thing about music,
figuring out one little thing about a
module,
one of my sense and what it does and
understanding it and then like unfolding
that into something bigger and that can
lead to hours of,
of it.
Whereas like if I sit down and play God
of war,
you know that's also going to lead to
ours.
But at the end of it I'm going to know
more about a story,
whereas the other one I'm going to know
a little bit more about math and like
how sound works in general,
which is a fascinating thing altogether.
You know?
So I don't know.
What do you think?
Is there a hierarchy of shit to do?
Like
no,
I don't think there is.
I think there's a hierarchy and elevated
passion levels.
So like what are you passionate about?
Say if you were doing something and you
know,
you were very apathetic about it,
but then there was this other thing that
you did that once you started,
like for some people of the World Cup
was on today,
I went to get a cup of coffee and they
have the World Cup on and these guys are
gathering around watching the World Cup.
To me it's just dudes running around.
I don't know what's going on.
I don't know.
It's fine.
It's great,
it's good.
But for them it was clearly.
And for the world,
for all the people watching in the
stands is an elevated level of passion
for that.
Now,
if that was your thing,
I would say maybe you can be a
commentator and maybe you can be a
player or maybe it could be someone who
produces one of those soccer shows or
something like that.
There's just plenty of gigs for that,
but if that's your thing and instead you
get into shoe sales,
like Al Bundy,
you know,
after awhile that shit chips away.
Just not what I like.
What I like is I want to play soccer,
I want to watch soccer,
I want to talk about soccer,
I want to commentate on soccer.
Yeah,
you got to find the thing and that
yellow gold,
not everybody can commentate on soccer.
Dad is true,
but it's also a loser mentality like
someone can.
Not everybody can,
but how many people try?
That's the other thing.
Like people say,
not everybody can be successful.
Comedian.
You're right.
How many people try though,
right?
Not that many people try.
A more people could do it then,
then try.
I think there's a bunch of people out
there that could.
I always tell you about.
I've told you about this guy,
my friend Dave Dolan,
who is my boss,
he's a private investigator.
When I was a kid,
I got a gig driving him around.
He needed an assistant.
Really?
He got a Dui and they took his license
away and needed a driver.
He was the funniest guy I've ever met.
He's right up there with Joe.
He was so funny,
man.
And you know,
not no aspirations for comedy at all.
And his cousin was Billy Downs who was
one of the owners of the comedy
connection in Boston.
So his,
his cousin was a former comedian who
owned the comedy club and just randomly
became friends with them from an ad on
like one of those newspaper ads for the
job seeking private investigators
assistant.
I'm like,
that sounds like a cool job.
So.
But this guy easily could have been a
comic,
like a hundred percent.
Could have been.
Sure.
He's a.
He was a funny fucking dude and he was
always the guy that has a bunch of
people were saying around.
He would say something like,
totally ridiculous looking in the eye
and say it and everybody would be
laughing.
It was just natural.
He was just a naturally funny guy.
Just didn't do it.
Did he liked being a private
investigator?
Loved it.
Loved busting people.
Cheaters.
Mostly people who were cheating on their
insurance.
That was mostly.
It was.
There was a few one.
He got one guy who kept asking him to
take pictures of his girlfriend getting
fucked by this giant bodybuilder.
Dude after wise like,
hey dude,
enough with this kinky shit.
I'm not giving you any more fucking
pictures through attitude.
He's like,
get the fuck Outta here with this.
He goes like,
what else do you want,
bro?
I got the pictures that are going to get
more pictures.
You fucking idiot.
That's so funny.
That's so funny that.
Why didn't the guy just hire a
photographer?
Right.
Well the guy was.
He was just like really wealthy but
diminutive.
Very non masculine man.
And he had this bombshell girl that he
had figured out a way to get a part of.
Yeah,
but she was just getting drilled on the
side.
Did she know he was getting pictures
taken?
I don't think she did.
No,
I don't think she's.
Sounds like,
to me it sounds like a fetish game where
he's like,
oh,
seems like a.
But I don't think it was.
I think it was just a weak guy.
Didn't know what to do because they
would be on the beach.
He get pictures of him on the beach
making out and stuff like he got.
He got enough pictures.
A lot of these guys.
I mean I don't.
Yeah,
I don't know man.
I just.
That to me sounds a little bit like,
well that's what he thought a little
bit.
He thought the guy was a little bit of a
freak,
but at the end of the day he was like,
look,
come on.
You know,
it was fucking heavy Boston accent,
Bro.
I got you.
You fucking pictures did make a move.
Right?
Not taking any more.
Clf Sucks.
That's a shit job.
I wouldn't want to do that.
He loved busting people.
That's not his thing.
He didn't really like.
That was rare.
Most of the time he worked for insurance
companies,
most of the time it's like say if you
were married and you were a woman and
you had a different maiden name,
you would get injured on the job and
then you would start using your maiden
name and take a job on the side while
you're getting workman's compensation.
So people would get double paid.
Yeah,
and they would have to leave their jobs,
like people would leave their job super
early in the morning so we would camp
out in front of people's houses where we
would get there at 4:00
in the morning when everybody's asleep.
We'd sit in the car across the street
and we'd wait sometimes earlier and we'd
wait and we'd wait and we wait 5:30
roll around and then you'd see some
light go on and you're like,
he's up,
he's up here.
He goes,
here he goes,
this motherfucker's going to work and
this is the guy that's supposed to be
laid up in bed.
And we catch them like working as a
roofer carrying shingles up the ladder
when they're getting disable a
disability insurance.
Yeah.
So that was a really common thing.
Most of it was disability insurance
man.
What a fucked up state of life to get
into.
Or you're doing insurance fraud.
Like that's a.
that's a sad existence to like get into
that spot where you're like,
I'm going to get.
I'm going to give it to them,
man.
I've come up with a scheme,
honey,
you know someone from the comedy store.
I probably can't it
sometimes.
It's not like that man.
See,
this is the thing.
Like it was nice people,
they just didn't know better and I don't
say that like they're stupid.
I say that like they're just dating.
I think they're going to get caught.
They didn't think it was that big a
deal.
They didn't think through it very well.
There was one lady was so nice.
She,
he had a scam.
This scam safe your license plate
number.
He would write down your license plate
number and then write down one that was
really close to it and write down
another one that was really close to
that.
And then he would knock on your door and
he'd say,
I hate to bother you.
But my girlfriend was in a car accident
and the police report where they had the
witnesses driver's license number,
a,
some coffee got spilled on the report
and they don't know exactly what the
license number is.
There's.
We've checked these two.
It's not them.
I have a friend who works in the DMV and
they hooked me up and then you tell her
an injury.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
What?
What happened to a showcase?
She's okay,
but she did this.
Oh my God.
I had that same injury.
You tell them the injury that they had
that's giving them Workman's
compensation and had St.
that's terrible.
Do you guys want to come in and have a
cup of coffee?
She invites us in that fucking house.
Strangers.
This is what people did in the eighties,
dude.
They invited people in the house like
pilgrims these crazy.
This lady invited two guys into her
house and he spins or a yarn about his
girlfriend being injured and she said I
had the exact same problem.
And he said,
well,
what happened?
She said,
well,
I was on the job as a flight attendant
and I fell down and hurt myself,
and he goes,
Bob,
you getting paid aren't you?
And she goes,
oh,
not only getting paid,
but I'm also working under my maiden
name and another job.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
great,
great idea.
Way To do it,
lady.
So Nice.
And we got out of there and I was like,
man,
we can't turn her.
And he's like,
fuck her.
She goes,
she goes,
she's a fucking crazy.
He goes,
that lady's a fucking crook.
I mean,
she's so nice.
She let us in her house.
She gave us coffee.
That's the car.
I love that Shit,
man.
I like being nice has somehow become
synonymous with not being dangerous or a
crook.
That's a really funny thing.
It's like because being nice is like,
that's like a really great costume to
put on.
Like if you want to camouflage yourself
and you're a predator,
you know the way lot the tigers wasn't
okay.
Predator.
She was just a lady who didn't think it
was a big deal to rip off a corporation.
People grow up thinking corporations are
faceless,
nameless entities and you can extract
money from them.
I think that's the way people think of
some liability lawsuits.
Like you slip on some water in the
hallway and a big building.
You fall down like,
oh,
I'm hurt.
I'm real hurt.
You guys didn't protect me.
My balance was compromised and I fell on
your ground.
Somebody.
Somebody put some water on your ground.
I'm not responsible for this.
I'm going to soup soup.
Soup.
It's fucked.
It's bad that,
that,
that woman was making a terrible
mistake.
And your,
um,
your friend Dolan,
dynamite,
dickless Dave Dolan and calm.
So he helped,
he helped her,
he helped her out because like that kind
of shit,
that kind of life like dealing,
you want to create like a,
you want to create a version of that
woman were like inside.
She didn't feel alone at least a little
bad,
a little better,
a little weak,
a little bit off balance course,
but reality,
the reality is she didn't feel good
about that probably.
And that's not a great way to live,
man.
And,
and so by getting corrected by the
universe in those ways,
you know,
I think it's a good thing.
I'm glad that,
you know,
some things aren't illegal for example,
but they are,
you know,
like obviously like we agree on some of
these things,
right?
Those things,
it's fucked up to bus people for if
you're stealing in,
uh,
in,
in that,
in that way.
I don't know man.
No,
you're right.
But I would have never turned around.
I would have said this.
I can't,
that would have never been a good
private investigator.
I just,
I,
I feel like a lot of those people and I
was at the time 21 at the time,
at the most 21.
I think at that time I was really well
aware of like the,
the neighborhood where my grandparents
grew up,
right?
Like,
and,
and being around them and being around
my parents who grew up in the sixties
and then my grandparents who grew up,
I mean they were,
they were hearing the depression and
they just,
there was a different attitude about
opportunity.
Like everybody was poor.
Right.
So everybody would like take advantage
of every opportunity and if you've got
an opportunity to run a scam,
you did it.
Yeah.
And there's this terrible thing that
happens in,
in poor communities is that people do
think of like insurance scams,
this kind of scam.
Like you know,
you gotta think about it like a score,
you know,
think about it like it's a score.
I've heard say that to me
right now,
an older Italian guys.
Look,
you've got to think about this.
This is a score.
Okay?
Can't fuck this up.
You got an opportunity here.
All you have to do is you go to the
fucking chiropractor.
My back hurts.
They can't tell you why your back hurts.
Nobody knows why you fucking back hurts.
Which is true.
You would go to a chiropractor every day
and say,
my back is fucking killing me.
I got a shooting pain down my leg.
They can't prove it or disprove it.
Next thing you know,
you get a $35,000
check in the mail.
Oh,
right.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
man,
here's the thing.
Number one,
I felt like I have to say this,
I would not have turned this fucking
that woman in if I was not a private
investigator,
but that'd be in Dolan ethically had to
turn her in because if he didn't he
would be guilty of stealing from the
person who was giving him money to do
the job.
There was never a question.
Right.
So that's what he did for a living.
He was turned around,
but the,
the,
the main like problem with stealing a
like,
you know,
sometimes I've been hanging out with
people you leave a grocery store and
somehow they didn't charge for like a,
I dunno,
a bottle of water or whatever.
Like they didn't see it in the car.
Right.
And the people,
some people are like,
I did it.
Free water.
They fucked up.
Right.
And like man,
I think those people are unaware of this
like weird law in the universe,
which is that you seem to like have to
get shipped back times three,
it feels like maybe a little bit more
than that when you give or take or to.
So like if you steal a $2 bottle of
water,
now this is my superstition,
you're going to end up paying like at
least six bucks for that bottle of water
in some other way.
Some Karmic,
some shit's going to happen.
You're going to get a parking ticket,
you're going to get some weird fucking
thing.
So I think a thief is unaware of a
metaphysical economy,
which is like,
you think you're going to get away with
that,
but you're not like,
if you could really get away with it,
it would give me pause.
But like I've noticed man,
all my friends who are really
successful,
they leave giant fucking tips,
crazy tips,
you know,
a few of these people,
Joe tips were like,
it makes the waitress cry.
And also I've noticed they will dodge
out of a place before they can be
acknowledged for leaving some insanely
massive tip to.
I'm right here.
You don't have to talk about milk.
I'm not here,
I just don't want to fuck it.
Embarrass you man.
Because it's like,
you know,
a lot of don't.
But the main thing is like that's a love
bomb.
That's why I was called up.
Yeah,
leave a love bomb for the winter.
Right.
But I think also there's another side to
it that is more than just like the
feeling you get of knowing you've been
generous and you're not that attached to
money.
No,
it's not even that.
So you get an opportunity to give a
nudge in a positive.
They feel good so that they feel good.
It looks so.
It gives you a hundred dollar tip for a
fucking cup of coffee or something.
They get this feeling like,
Holy Shit.
All of a sudden a beautiful feeling of a
normal situation,
just a normal interaction.
I give you this and you can give me
that.
And I say,
thank you.
And I go,
well,
in that normal interaction,
all of a sudden,
boom.
You get this beautiful gift from a
stranger that didn't know how to do have
to do that for no reason at all.
Just a little love bomb.
Yeah.
It's.
It's even better when you're not there
when you're in the car driving and they
realize you left before him.
Right,
see that thing right there,
man,
that if you go back to what we were
talking about about momentum.
Yeah.
Puts a little ripples out there.
Those ripples spread.
Yeah,
and it's not just with that obviously do
it with money.
No,
it's being nice to people.
Sometimes.
I've had days where like I'm just
walking somewhere and someone looks at
me and they go,
hey,
hi.
How are you?
Everything good?
Yeah,
man,
everything's good.
How you doing?
I'm doing good.
Enjoy the day.
It's just so nice little friendly
interaction with some person who never
met before and for no reason.
Just wants to be a nice guy.
Those make you feel good,
man.
Those are.
Those are nice moments and contract.
Conversely,
weird moments that I've had where people
that are distracted and they're looking
at their phone,
they're not paying attention.
I'm like,
this fucking dummy that almost ran into
me.
I don't have to think that,
whether it's a dumb way to think,
but I do think it,
especially if it's like a kid,
you know,
some fucking kid just trying to push it.
Where's the opposing army?
And they almost run into you like,
hey dude,
your phone.
Right,
right.
They are radiating this momentum into
the world.
They're not interacting with people that
are there.
Versus a person who's like genuinely
nice is I just see someone walking down
the street and they say,
good morning,
good morning.
Yeah.
And everybody feels good.
That's just a nice little thing like
that.
That's right.
Those are those men,
those spread,
that person might do it to the next
person they meet and then boom,
everybody's saying hi to everybody and
everybody's hugging everybody.
This is it.
Yeah.
That's.
We talk about this probably every time
because we both agree that this is like
probably if there was going to be a
nonviolent revolution in this country
that wasn't based on voting,
it's going to start with that.
And,
and,
uh,
in what is that,
you know,
in,
in the,
the thing I'm being taught is that thing
you're talking about,
it can be cultivated and refined so you
can sort of,
that's why it's called a practice.
Like when you're sitting and you're
watching your breath and you're learning
how to be in the moment instead of
thinking,
I'm doing this for this reason or that
like I'm doing this because when I'm
like talking to somebody,
they're going to think I'm spiritual.
I'm doing this because I want to be more
focused.
I'm doing this because I have an anxiety
disorder.
I'm doing this because of this or that.
That's great.
But there's another reason to do it,
which is that,
uh,
if you get really good at being in the
moment with people and also when you're
sitting with yourself,
uh,
and learning who you are,
you have to start applying a lot of
compassion to yourself because you're
going to sit man and you're going to.
Some shit's going to float to the
surface of the stream that you wish had
stayed under some rocks.
Man,
you're going to see not just shit that's
been done to you,
but you're going to see shit that you've
done other people and you're going to
have to deal with that.
Right?
And the.
And the way to deal with that is,
is not to do like,
I don't know if you do this at all,
but sometimes like I will remember
something from when I was very young and
be like,
you fucking Dick.
I'll say it out loud to nobody yelling
does someone like 15 years ago,
right?
Yelling at you at my past self like you
motherfucker,
you know,
what have you got me into with my
memory's Jesus Christ ban?
Why were you doing that?
Why did you do that?
And so that's like the opposite of
compassion for the self.
Right?
So anyway,
the point is if you can like sort of
cultivate compassion for who you are
right now,
that's not to say use that as an excuse
to not try to become a kinder person.
But I'm saying cultivate compassion for
the fact that like,
man,
your dad had ptsd and you're fucking a
folks got divorced when you were three
and your dad remarried an abusive woman
who hated your fucking guts for seven
fucking years.
And she did some really bad things to
you over the course of that time that
you are way too young to process or you
had no,
you had no way to deal with that and now
when you're in,
you're in your twenties or thirties,
you're realizing that you seem to be
kind of a selfish cunt.
And it's like,
well,
yeah,
the reason you're being a selfish quote
comment is because you had to build up a
very high powered defense mechanism to
deal with the fact that you were abused
for almost a decade when your brain was
forming more neurons than it ever will
at any other point in its life.
And now we can start having compassion
for ourselves.
Instead of thinking,
I'm a selfish cunt.
We could think,
oh,
I've got too big a force field up.
I've developed a thing to protect me
from an environment that I'm no longer
in.
And then the point is,
once you start becoming compassionate to
yourself,
that's when you run into the person
who's being a selfish cunt,
who you can look at and say,
oh,
I see you.
I know you are.
I don't know what it was.
I don't know if it was an abusive
parent.
I don't know if it was a heartbreak.
I don't know if it's something you read.
I don't know if it was something I don't
know.
Maybe genetic,
I don't know,
but I know from looking into myself
enough to know that you deserve more
compassion than you're getting.
That's it.
So we have this agreement that everybody
can learn up to a certain point.
Right?
We agree that pretty much everyone who's
normal and not impaired mentally can
learn how to read.
Right.
We agree this,
we agree to this.
I think say,
yeah,
we agree to simple mathematics.
Everyone can learn how to add and
subtract and multiply and after that it
gets a little squirrely with division
people can't come,
but we're.
We're agreeing that with minimal paying
attention in school,
we could all achieve a certain level.
Yes,
but there's very little very little
attention ever paid to considering how
you behave and how you think and how you
observe yourself and how you correct
mistakes and how you learn from the
past.
It's never taught.
It's one of the most important things
I've ever learned in my life is to to
not cling onto the past,
but don't forget it either.
That's great.
Remember that you fucked up.
Don't do it again,
but don't live in this world of 20 years
ago or 30 years ago or whatever.
That one instance where you wish you
didn't say this one thing to some person
or hit some person or drive your car
where you should and whatever the fuck
it is,
whatever.
Whatever thing that it was that you
still sit back and go,
God,
yeah.
You know,
I've,
I rear ended.
Somebody wants with my car when I was on
my way to selling it and I wasn't paying
attention at a red light and my scars.
I had a,
I think it was a 1978 oldsmobile cutlass
and the front end.
I crunched this guy's bumper with the
fiberglass part of my car.
Didn't do shit to his car.
He had a truck,
but I fucked up my car on the way to
selling it and I brought it to this
person and the grill was like half
hanging off and I remember in my car
just going,
fuck,
I just fucking.
I was.
I was so broke and such a loser.
I'm barely keeping it together and on my
way to selling this car,
I fucked it up and I was just like,
you fucking loser.
Yeah.
I remember being in my car screaming at
myself,
you fucking loser.
And I remember the guy bought it anyway,
just took a bunch of money off of it.
I forget what we agreed on.
Um,
but,
but this feeling would haunt me for
months,
for months.
I'd be doing other things and I would
think of rear ended that car not paying
attention fucking up the.
I'm like,
yeah,
because it wasn't even like an accident.
It was like I left my foot off the gas
and it just slammed into somebody
because I wasn't paying attention.
Right.
Oh yeah.
So I let my foot off the brake rather.
It was,
it was something that I literally was
defining myself by for months.
I was thinking that I was a loser
because I did this.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's it right there.
I said like,
Hey asshole,
don't let your foot off the brake.
Pay attention what you're doing.
You're driving a fucking car.
I know you're only 18,
but pay attention to what the fuck
you're doing.
It wasn't,
it wasn't that it was you fucking you
fucking
loser.
Screaming at myself,
Dude.
I was talking to this,
this dude at one of these randazzo
retreats.
He's like in his twenties and like,
I'm,
I'm really,
by the way,
this wasn't a row.
I'm like really,
like veiling the person very,
very deeply here.
But the point is this person was telling
me some shitty thing that had happened
to them when they were a kid.
Right.
And a real young and uh,
like it happened like at a,
at a doctor's office.
The doctor,
like it was like a shitty doctor or
something,
I don't know.
But the doctor like slap,
slap the kid,
right?
Geez.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
for what reason?
Well,
there's no reason is there joe,
like there's really no reason to slap a
kid.
He's come to a doctor's office.
Right?
So for sure.
Right.
What was the reasonable thing?
The kids,
that's the thing my friend said.
My friend said,
well,
I was squirming around.
Oh Geez.
He hadn't considered.
He hadn't even considered that he was
five.
So like I said to him,
I'm like,
hey man,
have.
When was the last time you picked up a
five year old?
Do you know how small five-year-olds
are?
Do you understand that you didn't do
anything wrong?
Did that was a shitty doctor that was a
crazy fucking doctor and your whole life
to rationalize the fact that sometimes
big people are crazy and slap little
people.
You tried to apply some logic or like
tilt to the act itself right now,
that's a heavy burden to carry because
if you think you're a bad five-year-old,
you're probably going to think you're a
bad 30.
God knows are going to think you're a
bad 35 year old.
All the crazy shit you can do when
you're 35.
So it's like that mentality of looking
back on our former self and hating it is
the very same reason that we hate
others.
It's identical.
If I'm going to hate myself,
definitely I'm giving myself permission.
Eight everybody else around me.
And that's so the work is let's figure
out how to like be compassionate to our
former selves and not just when we were
fucking kids in a doctor's office and
not just 10 years ago and not just 20
years ago,
like start and start now.
Like right now,
because you're sitting on top of a card
house made of memory.
Right?
And it's like that.
You're the entire thing.
So you got to love it all and then then
if you start doing that shit,
I have noticed your degree of country
drops by a lot.
It's not going to go away.
It will definitely,
at least for me,
I mean,
one of the things that we've,
I've had many guys asked me before,
why do you,
why are you so insistent on exercise?
It's a big one.
Do you really think it helps you?
I'm like,
I know it helps me.
I don't want.
It's like jerking off,
but for the body,
like instead of the,
the,
this,
this thing that you get when you jerk
off this relief from the need for sex,
there's an noticed tension that's
constantly in your bio that flavors the
way you think about things.
It really just does.
Um,
last night my daughter was upset at
something.
She had gotten to a little tiffed with
one of her friends,
super upset and really her friend,
she thought her friend was being mean
and just didn't,
you know,
trying to deal with it.
We went into the garage and uh,
I said,
let's just go.
We'll work out.
You'll feel better.
And I put the pads on and we started
moving around,
start throwing some kicks and punches,
start breaking a sweat.
Really getting into whap whap whap and
getting him,
Woo.
This is fun.
And then laughing and joking around and
then we talked about it because I'm
like,
now you can talk about it rationally
because now it's not fucking with you
too.
You have this energy that's pent up.
Yeah.
You got to let that energy out and then
you're left with the thoughts.
But too many people get stuck with the
energy and the thought and the energy is
overwhelming the thought,
and it's like,
oh,
this fucking emotional.
Yeah,
and I run around the block or a fucking
hitting the heavy bag or hitting the
pads or skip some grub or whatever
you're into.
Take a yoga class.
Whatever you wind,
do,
drain the stress out of the body and
then look at the object and the,
the idea for what it is.
And this is a fucking important method
of managing the way you think about
things that people overlook.
They overlook the impact of physical
tension on the body and your decision
making process.
Uh,
wow.
Yeah.
Do do you a.
do you believe that trauma is stored in
the body?
You think that's bullshit?
I don't know.
I mean,
I know that trauma is something that
clings inside your subconsciousness.
Your subconsciousness is a part of your
consciousness.
Your consciousness supposedly resides in
your body.
So why wouldn't it be in your body
somehow way,
shape or form,
right?
You know,
there's also the idea that there's parts
of your body that retained memory,
not just your brain,
but there's neurons in your body and
perhaps they retain memory,
like there's the concept that this
apparent there's some type of neuron in
the heart,
right?
Yes.
And this is what a lot of people believe
was responsible for this idea of like
follow your heart,
follow your heart.
Maybe if those are your memories and
your,
your database of collective emotional
ideas.
If there's really something to that and
like maybe it's not just in the brain
area but also in the heart area and in
all the neurons.
Maybe we just,
we just think because our consciousness
resides in the brain,
that all of our memories reside there as
well and that they're not in various
areas of our body.
People that get transplants,
man,
one of the weird things that they say,
they,
they find that they have cravings for
things like the person who donated the
Oregon.
Right?
Right.
I don't know if that's real or not
because obviously I've never gone
through a transplant,
but
I've heard that shit a lot too.
And,
and someone was explaining it to me
like,
well,
Oh god,
here comes fucking Bro.
Scientists Trust.
Get ready.
Here we go.
I'm ready.
Dr Trussell.
I've got a fucking masters degree in
Bro.
Science.
Oh yeah.
Dude do.
Are you working tonight?
Yeah,
Dude.
I am like,
yeah,
why?
What's going on?
Ice House?
I can't do it.
That's okay.
I'm a dude.
Thank you so much though on.
I was just thinking before I do my bro
Science thing,
man,
your daughter's fucking lucky.
God Damn Your Dad's like,
let's go to the gym in the House and
fucking kickbox you're upset.
That's super cool man.
I was just thinking that.
The other thing.
Well it's
only cool if they like it.
The thing is she likes to do it.
This is one thing that I think is
extremely important because I see people
that get their son to play football
because they played football and the kid
doesn't want to play fucking football.
Yeah,
man,
you got to let your kids be who they
are.
They get super resentful.
I've seen people raise their kids and
try to force their kids into holes.
You got to support them and love them
and let them find their path.
You have to.
You have to let them find their path.
You can't decide they're going to be a
doctor or decide they're going to be a
lawyer.
Decide they're going to be whatever the
fuck you want them to be.
They they got to be what they are.
We're all so different and you are
literally robbing a kid of their future.
If you over influence their choice
making in terms of like not following
their passion or their dream or their
ideas.
You and it can be done,
and this is to say that it can't be done
is it's all so many people can't do it.
So many people don't get their
doctorate.
So many people don't ever become
scientists or astronauts or fucking
mathematicians.
A lot of things are hard to do,
man,
right?
A lot of things.
Right,
but you can't decide the way that kids
brain works.
You're not in there,
right?
You're not in there and it's different
than yours and hers is different than
his right.
His brother is different than this
sister and the mom is different than all
of them and you've got to let people be.
You got to let them be.
You have to in people don't.
And those fucking people hate their
parents.
Those people did to develop this fucking
resentment because there's no freedom
there.
Fucking mom is always on.
I'm mom.
I don't want to do that.
You just stopped.
I raised you.
I didn't raise you to talk to me like
this.
You're my son.
I don't want you being a loser.
Do you?
Will get it.
Do you understand it?
Like,
ah,
yeah,
I don't want to be a doctor.
Yeah.
I'm so disappointed in you.
I know friends where their parents don't
talk to them anymore because they
changed majors.
Yeah,
they changed majors.
A Dad stop talking to them.
What side?
Yo,
you don't want.
You don't want to take on the company
business.
You don't want to take the company.
You have.
The idea
was we were going to send you to go to
school when you were going to take over
the company business.
Yeah.
Maybe in a band you fucking loser.
Some people have a really.
It's like we got to be so much kinder to
people when you just think in shit like
that helps you understand how people are
like you run into just about anybody
man,
and it's like so easy to,
to have someone in your life and enjoy
the idea that they're an asshole and
they deserve it,
but if you spend just a speck of time
thinking about it,
it's like if we really sat in a weird
way,
it sucks.
We'll just wait until you have kids.
Then it gets really,
really interesting because you start
looking at people like they used to be
babies.
That's what happened to me.
Boy,
come and man,
are you do I don't like?
Yeah,
this is the first place I've said it.
Holy Shit Daddy.
She said it's okay.
You know you get when,
when you're in the early Montero.
I don't know
why,
but like if you're scared,
it's such a sacred thing.
You know?
It's a vulnerable thing to talk about.
It makes you feel vulnerable.
It makes you feel nervous and because of
the energy or you're worried about
talking to fucking love it,
it is the most transformative,
like,
you know,
like you hear all the time to the point
where I was like suspicious of it.
Like I was like,
you know,
I don't stand up has done this job for
awhile,
so I think I'm allowed to say I urge you
not,
should I not even what's,
what's the.
Yeah.
He doesn't do any.
His old stuff.
He's got some of my favorite jokes of
all time.
Many of them.
But he's got this killer fucking joke
about Alva like a pregnant people are
like heroin addicts,
you know?
They're like,
just try it.
You'll love it.
Just try it.
And then.
And then when you do it,
like,
you know,
you're stuck,
you're trapped.
Which is how I used to think.
But man,
it's so humbling to realize that all
this shit you heard that was true in the
sense that you hear people say,
oh no,
it's psychedelic psychedelic.
Now I,
I always associated that with like when
the baby's born,
there must be some serotonin or dopamine
that gets released,
not just in the woman.
We know the woman's brain is flooded
with oxytocin and a variety of things.
The mother,
the bonding chemicals,
but you know,
I thought,
well that clearly would happen for the
father,
maybe just not in the same level.
So when people say it's Psychedelic,
that must be what they meet,
but now I know you know,
the birth is,
hasn't happened yet,
but just being in the presence of a
person who's growing a life inside of
their belly and realizing that like the
bonding that's happening there and like
the sacred duty is coming up.
If you being a father and that a soul is
coming into this dimension that is going
to be.
I'm completely dependent on you and my
wife course wanting to keep her safe and
then man,
it.
The combination of all these things is
so incredibly psychedelic and the most
beautiful way and so humbling because
it's like,
boy,
oh boy,
did I fucking tell myself that.
I'd figured out something really smart
and that was like reproduction is a
trick of the DNA and this marriage thing
and the baby thing is some kind of vast
digital societal Oregon,
like the opinion decks.
We don't need to do that.
There's nothing to it.
Obviously I wasn't using that voice,
but like,
it was such a pretentious fucking
pompous,
ridiculous place that I was standing at,
which is to judge people for
reproducing,
having,
enjoying the ability to judge because my
parents reproduced.
You know what I mean?
So it's so humbling to realize like,
oh,
I was wrong,
but I wasn't just like kinder on,
like I was deeply fundamentally,
completely wrong about this phase of
life in this.
Uh,
what's the word for it?
This,
um,
well,
I like,
in Hinduism they call it an Ostrom,
like a monastery.
It's called the Green Hosta Ostrom.
It's like a temple.
It's considered to be like a temple.
The family.
Holy Fuck Man.
It's real.
The rubbers hit the road man.
And it's like,
it's really,
really beautiful though,
obviously a little scary.
Yeah,
it's love.
It's real love.
And it's love where you know you're
going to be able to love your children
unconditionally in a in a very strange
way that we really have a hard time with
other people.
And I think the thing about it is not
just that you're bringing a life into
this world which is very psychedelic,
but that your love bond with this kid is
so ultimate.
It's so.
It's so intense.
The love that you have for each other to
raising the kid together.
There's a thing that happens with people
when they are just really deeply
connected at a DNA level.
Like this is a little person that is
literally come out of nowhere from two
bodies and it's.
It makes you realize how precious life
is,
how vulnerable we all are.
And it makes you realize that it's such
a cliche phrase,
the actual power of love.
And then it's not just the love of this
kid or the love of yourselves,
the two together and the family together
and all the other people that you love.
It's a love of all people.
It's the love.
It's just if we just really have a hard
time loving people,
we have a really hard time.
The people going to love us
back or they're not gonna get in our
way.
They're not going to be overly needy or
annoying or they're not going to be
intrusive or they're not going to tell
you what to do,
which is why people hate their fucking
parents telling them what to do.
Oh,
it comes with this bullshit.
Love comes with this nonsense.
Love comes with fucking rules and I have
to be annoyed all the time.
I have to wear my suit on Sunday.
Fuck love.
Fuck it.
I don't want it.
Then that carries on.
You develop these,
the shields that you put up for the
whole world.
Because of that.
That's one of the most common things
that people do when,
when in terms of like our definitions of
love,
we define it by the people that were
supposed to be the lovers in our lives,
but they'll just unconditional kindness
and love so so few people are balanced.
In the beginning of the relationship.
It's just lust and then after awhile you
get annoyed with each other and you
can't wait to get free and find somebody
else who's going to make you happy.
They don't make you happy either.
And most of us in the early years of our
lives in particular,
we bounce around,
you know,
we try to find a new person that's gonna
make us happy and we attract the kind of
people that are the most destructive for
us.
I mean for some strange reason,
we're always looking to be distracted.
Yes.
And when I think when you can learn how
to abandon that and it's not a learned.
Like now I know it's a slow gradual
process where the instances of
continuous occur less frequently,
right?
Less and less and less and less
frequently to your more and more and
more kind.
And then you,
you know,
you get it as good as you can get it on,
on any given day.
And that's part of being the hairless
ape in this strange land of electronics
and you know,
and concrete buildings.
We're still trying to figure out the
rules to this completely new way of
living.
And part of this completely new way of
living has shifted over the last 10
years and that's where the Internet
comes in the last 10,
20 years,
no more than 24 years.
The whole world's changed topsy turvy up
to down.
I mean the whole thing is just different
now.
It's a different reality.
Anybody from any point in the past,
if you transport them to today,
they'd be living in some fucking blade
runner movie.
I mean it really is a Ridley Scott Film.
You know for sure.
If you were living in the 19 fifties and
someone brought you to 2018 and picked
you up from the airport and a tesla,
you're on a plane.
Seems normal playing just like planes.
What are these screens on the seats?
Holy Shit.
And screens in the seats and someone
picks you up in a tesla.
It doesn't make any noise.
It's electric.
There's a giant laptop in the front of
it.
It shows this huge map and you're
driving around and people are taking
phone calls in the air.
It just,
Hey,
what's up Mike?
You're like,
what?
You're talking in the car?
What the fuck,
uh,
driving around to all these different
places and you see the,
the,
the mass of humans and the architecture
change and people would freak the fuck
out with the and this is the world that
we've totally,
completely become accustomed to.
That's right,
and no one,
no one's for this.
We're all just playing it on ear and the
worst aspects of it that some of the
chaos and those social upheaval and the
way the being,
the infighting between people,
people getting kicked out of restaurants
because they work for the wrong people
and put this.
If you see maxine waters telling people
that if you find people that it worked
for the trump administration,
you find them in a restaurant.
You find them anywhere.
You go and you get together a group of
people.
You build a crowd and you let them know
that you don't agree with their policies
like,
Whoa,
we're calling for gangs were calling for
gangs of people randomly industry to
interrupt people's meals,
interrupt people in stores.
Get a crowd together.
Don't let them be in.
Be Safe in public because you disagree
with their policies.
Woo.
This is getting crazy and I know one of
the policies of the immigrants,
the children of immigrants being
separated from their parents,
which I'm 100 percent with you.
It's immoral.
It's disgusting.
It saddens me that it's even considered
an option.
It makes no sense.
I don't give a fuck if they broke the
law.
You don't take parents and kids and
separate them.
You just fucking don't.
It's just disgusting.
There's other ways around it.
If you're saying,
well,
they shouldn't have broke the law.
Maybe they shouldn't have broke the law.
You don't get to do something that's a
thousand times worse than crossing a
line that dirt,
that fucking imaginary line in the dirt
crossing.
That is nothing in comparison to your
crime of stealing a baby from its
mother.
That's fucking insane.
That's not American.
Two thousand 18.
That's just insane and we wouldn't be
doing that to Canadians.
Okay.
If Canadians came over here with their
beautiful,
cute blond haired kids,
just were not stealing them from their
parents,
and that's one of the reasons why it's
sick.
The whole thing sick.
It's chaos.
So in one hand,
on one hand I understand where a lot of
people were outraged and I understand
where they're coming from.
You shouldn't separate parents from the
children in any way,
shape or form,
but the way to fix that,
as not saying anybody who's on that team
and working for that administration
should be chased by a mob of street
vigilantes.
And you should encourage this mom,
make a crowd,
get everybody together,
make some noise,
let them know they're not welcomed.
Like,
Whoa,
well isn't.
It isn't like who.
One of the,
one of the problems with it is now we
have a little bit of a slippery slope.
Like we let's,
you know,
I don't want to play mob justice ping
pong with you,
right?
Because if I start playing that with
you,
they're not ping pong could potentially
turn into a civil war.
Do you know there was a reason
USA Today poll that said 31 percent of
America thinks that we're close to a
civil war
right now.
Now that being said no.
And also people who like fantasize about
a civil war,
I don't know if they've really thought
it out all the way,
like what that looks like.
I can answer that for you.
They definitely have it.
Right.
So definitely have it because if they
did and they thought
it through and thought it was a good
idea,
they're out of their fucking minds.
They're crazy or they're stupid.
Yeah.
But,
but was really passionate about that and
that man.
Well,
I mean because he will,
he wants to fucking be in a goddamn
civil war.
But the,
the,
you know,
for me when I see shit like that going
down,
um,
I,
I see,
I've like come up with like I didn't
come up with,
I got it from the Dalai Lama,
but I've come up with like a good little
equation to,
to go back to which is does this reduce
suffering?
Right.
So like,
and I don't think it,
it reduces suffering.
And,
and these people who are really upset on
both sides of the fence are suffering.
Like we're,
we're really looking at like a world
where a lot of people are deeply upset,
deeply suffering,
and really scared and really,
really,
really freaking the fuck out.
And,
and as I've been watching this thing
emerge on the Internet,
on twitter where people tweet things
that paint that you look at it and you
think it's almost as though you're
living in another world than I am like
the world that you're,
you're talking about man,
it's fucking terrifying.
Like it's scary and it's like it's,
it's really fucked up.
And maybe like the reason I think that
is because I started doing lsd when I
was 16,
so when I was,
when I was 16 I w r I became brutally
aware of the fact that the current
government in the past government was
repressive and,
and,
and I,
and something about that drug,
which I don't do anymore because it's
illegal.
I was a crazy kid.
But something about that drug really
shows you the conditioning.
Right?
And so I knew from a pretty young age,
I was like,
Oh wow,
I don't,
I don't think the United States is,
is dropping bombs on other countries
because of justice or some threat.
It appears to be that some people are
making money off of this shit and I
don't think these drugs are illegal
because they're bad for you.
I think they're illegal because somebody
doesn't want the herd to experience
these states of consciousness because it
will make them more difficult to share.
I had this conversation with Hamilton
Morris yesterday and he strongly
disagrees because he's talked to the
people actually in the dea if she's
talked to the people in drug and forest
for sure.
And he said that what really is
happening is they have zero experience
with these drugs,
but they know these drugs are illegal
and so they pursue it as if it's a
viable target.
And we talked about it in terms of the
real problem with law enforcement
being that it's a game.
I've always said that the real problem
with tops is not cops.
The real problem with cops is human
nature.
This is a bad guy.
I get a point if I take him out,
you start looking for bad guys.
He started looking for bad guys that
aren't even there.
You start forcing situation.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I know comes.
Yeah.
Sorry.
No,
go ahead.
We get into this a lot.
I and I don't mean the dea,
like I've heard the exact same thing
about the dea.
Like they don't,
they,
I think people above them have
experienced.
I'm not even,
I'm not even talking about people above
them.
I'm talking about tendencies.
So like if an individual has a tendency,
right?
Like um,
tendency.
So a person has a tendency than a group
of people might have a tendency.
For example,
if I get a group of Swedish people
together and I'd bring them to the World
Cup,
they're going to have the tendency to
cheer for Sweden.
Right?
I'm going to bet on that.
I gamble on that.
There's a tendency,
right?
My boss fucking sucks.
He's a fucking asshole.
Right?
Then you think back to the way all your
other boss has acted and you realize
like,
wait,
there seems to be a tendency when people
are in that position of power to behave
in a certain way.
Right.
Hard,
hard job.
So,
so,
but what I'm saying is,
is the person who's in the position of
power,
is that thing coming from inside of them
or is it that there something like built
in to the DNA of a leadership position?
They say that like in the same way like
when you got a pregnant wife,
some new thing kicks in and I was
reading about it,
built in.
It feels like where it's like I'm
getting a fucking security system.
I'm fucking like,
you know what I mean?
I'm,
I want to make her safe.
I want to make sure that like we're,
we're saving money.
We're like,
you know what I mean,
I'm working harder than I've ever worked
in my fucking life because I want to
make sure that like there's plenty for
her and plenty for the kid and like
something kicks in.
There is a tendency there.
Right?
So what I'm saying is if there seems to
be a tendency that happens when there is
a,
uh,
a convergence of people in power,
right?
It starts behaving in a certain way.
It builds walls,
it starts taking people to jail who
don't belong in jail.
It dehumanizes essentially.
That's the fucking tendency,
right?
And so when you're taking a psychedelic
and you look around and you realize,
oh,
I see the government though,
it's filled with people who are
wonderful.
There are people in the fucking dea who
listened to your show and guaranteed
love the show.
And I'm like,
you're fucking right man.
I don't want to enforce these goddamn
laws.
Arresting people for a thing that is
like being shown not only to be
harmless,
but potentially therapeutic.
There's people in all branches of
government and there's some people who
just need a job and maybe there's some
assholes in there.
Well,
there's some people that want to bus
crack dealers.
You want to bust assholes that are
killing people,
happen to also be drug dealers.
And this is part of the job.
So I'm not talking about the individual
atomic structure
of the power structure,
I'm talking about the sum total
convergence,
the gestalt of the thing imminate
certain behavior patterns and those
fucking behavior patterns.
Those behavior patterns have been going
on for a very long time and so forever,
forever as far as we know,
there's always been kings.
So now I'm not saying therefore your
fear,
your terror is unjustified.
I just think maybe because of the
garishness of the current administration
compared to like Obama who is like,
you know,
we know what happened with Obama and,
and I say we know what happened with
Obama and the drones.
We know what happened.
Well,
we don't know what all the shit that
probably happened with Obama,
but we do know with Obama,
and I remember hearing this and then
looking it up and then looking it up
again.
Uh,
he apparently liked deported.
In fact,
maybe please find out if I'm wrong about
this.
I don't have to deal with 7 billion
people calling me a fucking motherfucker
for the rest of my life.
But apparently he deported more people
than any than all American presidents
combined.
His administration did.
Right.
Deported more people.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And,
and,
and so now trump,
he,
he's at the beginning of the fucking
deportation race.
Like by the time he's done,
he might have beaten Obama and score by
a long shot.
I don't fucking know.
But the main thing is what I'm saying
here is like,
I think I've been aware of the fact that
there is something wonky going on and
it's wonky in the most rotten brutal
way.
It's wonky in the sense that it kills
people.
It separates children from families,
not just of immigrants,
but if farmers,
some people were growing marijuana and
guaranteed their kids are in foster care
now and they're in fucking jail.
Right.
This has been going on and on and on and
on.
I think maybe now it's great about the
fear that we're seeing in the hyper
reaction is if there is anything great
about it,
is that people are waking up to the fact
that our government right now,
the American government is out of
balance.
We've been at war for 90 percent of our
history,
right,
and there's a lot of shit going on in
there that doesn't need to be going on
and we're waking up to it.
It's just some people are like,
they're waking up to it like they were
asleep and someone threw water in their
face and they're like,
oh fucking shit.
Holy fucking shit.
This is like,
you know,
this happened,
this sounds condescending.
I don't mean it to be,
but when I was like 18 or 17,
looking at a fucking dollar bell
tripping balls,
looking at that fucking green pyramid
and the weird symbols and then thinking
like,
wait a minute,
this,
this is covered with a cult symbology
all over it,
all over it.
And then thinking like,
wait a minute,
wait,
there's something,
this should,
this isn't really worth anything.
Like this is just paper.
And then setting it on fire,
you know,
just to do like the worst
thing,
like a joke obviously because it's
illegal to set it on fire.
Right?
Yeah,
of course.
It's a joke.
I will never fucking do that man.
No Way.
I never ever in a million years would
ignite currency,
not with old glory now without glory,
not with the fucking money,
but I guess what I'm saying is like if
there is something positive about and I,
the mobs of people doing this or that or
the other,
the hyper outrage almost as though we're
looking at an immune response.
Like that's kind of going over board.
Right?
Exactly.
But if there's something positive in it,
it's that it seems that huge swaths of
people are becoming familiar with the
machinations of the American empire and
understanding that here's how it's
working right now.
And um,
well not only that,
like this illusion that it worked far
differently when Obama was in office,
like,
have you seen that video?
Or Obama was running for president and
he started talking about how to deal
with immigration and the immigration
policies.
Now it's disturbing video because it's a
republican viewpoint.
He's the way he's talking about it,
it sounds like someone running for a
conservative position now.
It's not like this democratic socialist
idea of eliminating ice.
You know,
there's a lot of people that are there
ideas that immigration,
customs enforcement,
those people are monsters and we should
eliminate the position.
We shouldn't have it anymore and we
should have open borders.
And those,
those same people would love to have
Obama in office.
You know,
they would think that it would be great
if Obama was here.
Boy,
who was so much better when Obama was
here.
Back play that video,
find the video of Obama.
Uh,
I think it was,
I want to say 2007 or eight or something
like that,
something like that.
But it's one of those ones where you're
like,
Whoa,
wait a minute,
what?
Two thousand five.
You watch it and you go,
what?
Yeah.
Wow.
Like this sounds like a Republican.
Like imagine.
Let's just imagine and imagine this is a
young blonde white man who's saying this
in 2018.
Listen to this,
listen to listen to is his position
dude with one of us is like square on
the need to better secure the border at
a punish employers who choose to hire
illegal immigrants.
You know,
we are a generous and welcoming people
here in the United States,
but those who entered the country
illegally and those who employ them
disrespect the rule of law.
Wait,
can you pause that?
I'm sorry.
May I ask for a pots?
What's the date on that video?
Two thousand five,
that's for sure.
The date on the actual upload.
Flashback 2005,
seven,
zero.
S,
uh,
Senator Obama and immigration.
You use 31st 2017.
Okay.
Now here's the thing,
man,
his lips.
Look,
I be bullshit.
I've looked at that.
Obama has deported more people than any
American president,
but we have to be very careful these
days because if you look,
his lips aren't tracking.
Oh,
let me see.
Let me see.
Yeah,
go back
and look at the or showing disregard for
those who are following the law cannot
come out.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Does not tracking it all?
Well,
why don't you?
someone would know if that was a real
cspan thing.
I think we need to better secure the
border and a punish employers choose to
hire illegal immigrants.
I'm not saying this because I'm shocked
that yeah,
but it's just off,
but it's the same words.
They all agree.
He's saying the same words.
Can we find a version of it where it
doesn't do that?
Sorry,
you guys these days,
man.
I like so like,
and this is how we're going to deal with
even more like.
And also I'm not saying like you would
never do that.
I'm just saying that looks a little
fishy,
but you can just look up.
Did Obama deported more people than
those looking at it
before you asked me to fund the video
and I'm finding various problems in
that,
that statement or statistics.
So snopes has it,
but they've changed it to a mixture
instead of being true or false because
the definition of a deportation was
changed at some point in the last couple
of years.
The
point is he deported a lot of people,
you know,
like,
I don't know,
like how many are.
I don't know.
It wasn't Justin Trudeau.
He wasn't just open borders that nobody
in.
But dude,
let's please find out if that fucking
clip was actually sitting.
We would know.
We would know if that clip is bullshit.
There's no way they would just let it
slide if Obama never said that.
There's no way they would just let that
stay was sinked.
Well then you would kind of know because
that's a pretty famous clip and it gets
used all the time.
She spends website,
right?
We all agree on the need to better
secure what's up with the fucking dream
was declared illegal immigrants.
We are a generous and welcoming people
still offstage.
So yeah.
You guys are also watching a version
that's going through three different.
Are you watching it?
When was it published?
When was that uploaded?
This was uploaded 2005.
Okay,
great.
Perfect.
Sorry you guys.
You've got to be careful these days.
That man,
because they're fucking putting out shit
that looks real.
That is not.
I listened to that radio lab one where
they were showing how good it is today.
It's fucking.
It's close.
It's real close to being
indistinguishable.
Especially for you and I.
Yeah.
You and I have hundreds of hours of us
talking shit and saying things that are
ridiculous.
I mean,
we have,
you and I together probably have over a
hundred podcasts.
We've done way TC that stupid shit.
People make us say,
man,
I,
it's going to be so fucking
embarrassing.
It's embarrassing for you if you watch
it,
like there's a million things to watch
and to watch people put words in your
mouth.
Yeah.
You don't have to keep moving,
keep moving.
But Dude,
let's get back to this.
I like this topic here that we're
talking about,
which is like this.
There's A.
There's an imbalance here.
There's definitely an imbalance.
I think that imbalance is being exposed
by peoples' real opinion and this is one
of the reasons why actual education and
actual like raising of human beings is
going to be in critically,
critically important.
Whereas we ignored it as being not for
awhile.
Well,
it's way more important now because the
community
has gotten closer than ever.
The community of humans and by not
respecting this community and not really
concentrating on the way people behave
and think rather than what they own or
what their job title is or what degree
they have,
instead of concentrating on the.
One of the things that's most important
for us is the way we interact with each
other,
right?
Um,
we,
we have created this issue where now
that everyone has a word in,
you've got all these broken people chime
in,
in throwing an insult bombs and look,
anytime a woman is in the news who does
something remotely questionable,
the color of brigade comes out in full
force on twitter and it's all these fake
accounts and eggs and some people in
real accounts and just want attention
and they just attack.
I mean,
this is just a,
this is a real thing and it's not just
women,
but they do it to men,
to women.
It always takes on a particularly
viable,
creepy.
It's like finally I get to say this
thing and what?
Well,
what has happened there?
somebody's got raised badly.
Somebody,
somebody did a terrible job raising a
man that got them to this position with
this broken bundle of emotions and
memories and they're all fucked up with
no self esteem.
And then they find some little target
online.
Whatever it is,
fuck you Duncan Trussell,
you fucking sell out,
faggot.
And next thing you know,
they're attacking you and you might just
be about to go to the movies with your
wife and you read that,
like,
what the fuck is this guy's problem,
man,
I didn't do anything.
You put your phone down and you go into
that theater and you're all pissed off
and fucking tweet him back,
but you should this.
You can't.
There's too many people.
Too many people.
The bad thing is you're going to miss a
lot of good people,
but the good thing is you're going to
put a lot out.
Look.
You Go.
You have to put a lot of good out there,
but you can't dwell too much in the
back.
We're going to get through this.
This is a tumultuous adolescent stage of
human interaction.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's what's happening.
We're going to get through this and
reach a much higher level of
understanding of each other in a higher
level of understanding of community and
this is why all these school shootings
are happening and all this chaos and
people driving trucks into crowds and
shit.
It's because people are feeling out of
this,
this project of civilization and
culture.
They feel horribly suicidal and
depressed and confused and hateful and
angry and they're filled up with
chemicals and pharmaceuticals and
loneliness and despair and anger and
resentment and religious fervor and
whatever the fuck else is pushing them
through this life and then they react.
They explode and this more explode all
over the place,
but we got to take away the tools of
explosion.
No,
you've got to figure out why people are
exploding.
How come no one is concentrating on why
people were exposed was exploding every
once the women want to go,
it's toxic masculinity and the men want
to go.
We're raising pussies and nobody wants
to figure out what the fuck it is and
they just hope that it doesn't happen
again and then it happens again.
In the argument starts up and Ted nugent
calls everybody at coc and the fucking
people that want to guns taken away.
They all fucking storm in and they
demand and they ended the streak in
front of the senator's house at 2:00
in the morning.
Brigade roles in copper grade rolls in.
They started tweeting up a storm.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and this is,
this is where we're at,
where we're not examining the behavior
and the development of the human being.
It's a nonissue in our culture.
It's one of the most important things
about being a person.
You got to wait till you get to be 30
and he'd take a fuck.
An Anthony Robbins seminar.
I try to get your shit together with
some Voodoo preacher down in Malibu
that's doing some rock and roll church
Christian thing and all the cool people
go,
oh Jeez.
Oh Jeez.
Oh,
it's amazing.
The guy plays piano and he fucks
everybody.
He can.
It's chaos.
This is where we are.
We're this tumultuous stage where all
this information's flowing around and we
got to come up with management skills
management skills for behavior and
communication.
That's right.
And we have to recognize that we're all
in this together.
Dude,
I love that description is such a
perfect description and I think that's,
uh,
that's,
that's the main thing for everyone is
freaked out to remind themselves stuff.
It's like,
yeah,
of course you're freaked out.
Of course you should be the right way to
feel in a snow storm.
This is,
you're going to feel like I can't quite
see what's up.
So like definitely I have to be more
compassionate when I,
when I see people are super freaking out
because sometimes I judge them and then
they should be.
We all have to be more compassionate to
ourselves.
But then,
so if this is the state of chaos and
you're talking about management skills,
so to speak,
this is a thing.
This Guy Jack Kornfield,
who I have in my podcast sometimes
taught me,
this guy's an he's amazing.
He's a Buddhist teacher,
but he says tend to the part of the
garden that you can touch.
Right.
And I think that is such incredible,
incredible instructors agree with.
Put it.
Yeah,
that's a great way to put it.
Yeah.
So,
so it's,
it's like in all that chaos that you
just described where like you see the
thing and you realize like whatever it
may be,
the thing,
the school shooting,
the immigration,
the bus,
that whatever,
and you really,
you,
you get this in sad feeling,
there's nothing I can do about that.
And so you end up online,
you're scared.
Fear in Buddhism is cold.
Anger.
Like when fear gets hot,
it turns into anger.
So you're going to turn,
you're going to be angry because you're
scared,
and then you start firing these shots
online in the entire time you're doing
that,
the entire time you're doing that,
your mother who lives at the other,
you know,
somewhere in the middle of the country
is living by herself in a house where
she doesn't have enough money and the
house is dilapidated and you haven't
been paying attention to her.
She needs your fucking help,
right?
It's not time for you necessarily,
even though your aspiration to rebalance
a democracy is beautiful and we all want
that.
You're fucking neglecting one of your
best friends,
not your mom.
You know what I'm saying?
So someone you know is exhibiting like
some fucking behaviors that are like
awful little bit or like somebody in
your neighborhood or you know,
so it's like the whole time your mind
through anger is focusing on the fucking
press secretary.
Who,
by the way,
Joe,
I don't think the press secretary,
I could be totally off on this,
but you want to talk about shooting the
fucking messenger man,
that's it.
You perfect day when she's the
Messenger.
Literally.
Yeah.
You know what I mean like that,
that woman like that.
That is a messenger like is she.
Does she have the most pleasing
personality?
Do you agree with her politics?
Probably not,
but like,
come on man,
I'll tell you this morning,
imagine
if she didn't have that kind of
personality.
Imagine if she was cheerful and she went
up there and Jim Costa was fucking
screaming at her that his name,
Acosta,
whatever his name is,
but that guy gets heckled everywhere he
goes.
Now they put signs up behind him and
say,
CNN sucks.
There's some really fun things about the
trump administration,
some really fun things,
and one of the fun things is these
people that are journalists that takes
themselves super serious,
are they getting shit on for the first
time?
I mean,
they're getting.
They're getting called out for some of
their ridiculous behavior,
like yelling out questions during the
press conference,
like your questions more important than
all the people around you that might be
politely raising their hand.
You've decided you need the world needs
to know the world needs to know and they
get to hold these people,
hold their feet to the fire.
Okay.
Maybe,
maybe.
Maybe this is not the way to communicate
with people ever.
Maybe this maxine waters idea of like
getting people to protest people in
restaurants and build a crowd and let
them know that they're not welcome.
Okay.
Maybe that's the only way,
right?
Let's just play devil's advocate.
If you're looking at all these people
that are imposing these immoral
policies,
separating children from their parents,
which seems to be the most egregious.
That's the one that bothers us the most.
Everyone.
Yeah.
That's the one that's most horrific.
So how Amia bombing them?
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Well,
we know that that's far away.
That's not here,
but how do you stop that?
If you just let it happen?
These smiling demons just pass these
laws and laugh in your face and there's
no push back.
That doesn't work.
So what's the pushback?
How do you get push back?
This is where it gets weird.
They might have a point.
Okay.
If you're dealing with something that's
that disgusting,
as long as there's no actual violence.
If you're dealing with something that's
so heinous,
you're separating poor people from their
parents.
So they're just coming over here trying
to take a chance to get a migrant labor
ward job and they're trying to pick
strawberries or something.
And then you have ice come
in and steal them from their kids and
still their kids from them and yeah,
no you don't.
You can't come over here.
Who are you protecting?
Man?
Who's who?
Who were they competing with to get
these fucking strawberry picking jobs?
Nobody.
This is bullshit,
right?
How do you stop that from happening
while about.
What about the law?
So in the middle until this log gets
changed,
we reconsider the humane aspects of this
law.
How many people's lives are going to get
ruined,
how many thousands of kids are going to
get traumatically separated from their
parents and develop to become a more
fucked up person who truly resents and
hates the United States and get
molested.
Advice them ice age.
Oh Jesus.
Could that happen?
It did.
I'm sure it already happened.
I'm sure.
I'm not surprised on you want to know
the story.
It's that,
but how would you stop that?
I don't know how you would stop that,
but one of the only ways that I could
think of being really,
really effective in getting a message
across is to make it super uncomfortable
for people that push that message
through.
Sure.
What people that support that policy.
People that think it's not a big deal.
Cheer.
Jeff sessions gave a speech where they
made a joke about separating kids from
their families and the audience laughed.
Pull that.
Pull that up.
It's on.
It was on the cover of every new source
today.
Here we go.
Fucking sessions.
But this poor little fuck,
it's the same thing with him.
Like this guy,
he just stopped evolving and he got into
this and he's not getting information.
He's not getting it.
He's not.
He's not interacting with people who's
not evolving his ideas.
He stuck on this.
People who smoke marijuana are bad
people face some 1930 shit.
I know he's a moron.
You know,
in a lot of ways,
and this is the product of his
environment.
It's a product of his interactions and
the ecosystem and that he exists in.
He exists in this bubble.
Jeff sessions speaking out about
separating families
from the other side on this issue as on
many others has become radicalized.
We hear views on television today that
are on the lunatic fringe frankly,
and what is perhaps more galling is the
epoch hypocrisy.
These same people live in gated
communities,
many of them and our featured at events
where you have to have an id to even
come in and hear him speak.
I liked the little security around them
ourselves and if you try to scale the
fence of,
believe me,
they'll be even too happy to have you
arrested and separated from your
children.
It seemed like that joke was actually
written for him,
which is interesting.
Says the fucking guy getting people
arrested for marijuana.
What aloone?
Well,
you know,
obviously fucking dummy.
There's a big difference between someone
breaking into your house and break it
into the country to try to get a job.
You're not saying that people should
break into people's houses.
The main thing is jeff sessions is it
represents something in the world and
what that thing is is a force that is
actively
trying to reduce love in the universe
and it's fucking rail and so that's the.
If you want to come up with a nice war,
a name for what's happening.
This revolution that's happening and it
is,
is we're pushing back against that.
Okay.
Can I be the devil's advocate?
I'll be the devil.
Yeah,
sure.
That's not what he's doing.
He's supporting the law that we have a
law and this is how we keep a beautiful
country like America.
The reason why we have nice clean
streets,
the reason why I have cops social
security and it's because we have rules
and as soon as we just allow people to
bypass those rules,
people that don't agree with our way of
life,
don't they?
They don't,
don't support our way of life.
They just want to come over here and
Mooch off the system.
That's harder for you.
It's harder for him.
It's harder for everybody else.
All Johnny tax payer out there has to
pay for these migrants so you don't even
know.
They're not even a part of your clan
from another close by Cloud Jeff.
But here's the bigger problem.
This is the big problem in.
Okay,
and you're right.
Everything you just said,
Mr.
sessions too legit to quit.
Hey,
as far as like the rules of the game and
in some ways I guess it's true,
but like if we look at it from a bigger
perspective,
which you type really doesn't like at
all for some reason,
but maybe it's just because you're old
and your body probably hurts a little
bit and also that fucking butt plug that
I would bet $200,000
that you have shoved into your asshole
right now.
Think I think all the fucking time and I
think it's like,
I think I,
I get the,
I get a big bdsm vibe from that dude,
but that's just me.
I don't think it's true.
I don't know.
Here's my point,
man.
You know,
there's a bigger thing happening and
that bigger thing is,
is,
is just,
it's for a lot of people it's
unpalatable because it's so complex and
we don't yet know how to do it,
but we live on a planet and you say this
all the time where we are all people.
We are planetariums,
we are earthlings,
right?
We happen to have been born into a
country this country or that country.
Some of these countries have big fucking
walls around them because there's
prosperity inside that country and
there's prosperity inside that country
and there's not prosperity and other
places and people are suffering.
They're suffering bad,
bad,
bad suffering where it's like there,
there's like they can't.
They can't live in some of these places
without getting killed,
for sure.
The chance of them getting killed as
high for whatever reason,
and they're just doing what any living
organism does.
They're trying to get to a better spot.
Also,
Mr sessions,
you probably don't believe in it,
but once those fucking ice caps melt,
holy fuck.
When the cities in the next 50 years or
so become inundated with water and
people have to start moving more and
more and more from places that are
becoming uninhabitable.
What do you think that's gonna Happen?
I don't know man,
but let's say it's.
Let's put.
Let's make a long date.
So what do we do Duncan?
We just open up the borders for
everybody.
Mr.
Sessions,
I don't fucking know,
but I can tell you this.
If we start approaching this from the
perspective of love,
which is the perspective of like we
don't need to separate them from their
kids and there might be a way to do
this.
That eases their suffering a little bit
more.
I don't know what it is,
but my.
From looking at what you're doing right
now that a net and I think we can do it
better.
I don't know what it is,
but I think if we get a lot of people
together and really think about it and
figure it out,
I'm not talking redistribution of wealth
or some kind of crazy communist shit.
I'm just saying I know for sure we can
do better than those God damn aluminum
blankets you're putting on those fucking
kids.
Can we get a guitar player in here?
Hey,
maybe we can get some beds in here.
Is there a way to like,
you know,
there's just all kinds of shit we could
do.
I think that's better.
What am I going to do?
Why would that help though?
When the people are still gonna come
over here.
This is going to be in prison.
So you play the guitar,
is that right?
No,
I'm not saying play the guitar to solve
the immigration problem that worked.
I'm sure the immigration problem would
be solved.
I'm just saying that the current
methodology seems to be a little more
sadistic than it needs to be.
That's all.
I don't know the answer.
I don't know what the answer is,
but I do know we're converging as a
species and I would imagine that as
technology continues to connect us,
we're going to be transcending
nationalities in a way that aren't going
to be palatable to people like jeff
sessions.
And I think that that's a,
um,
that's what's happened.
So what do we do now?
What would you like?
Honestly,
like,
I'm not jeff sessions anymore on me.
Now.
Me.
Hey dog again.
What would you do
well for?
Okay.
I,
I'll give you my response to that,
which isn't going to be right because I
don't really.
I don't understand the issue at a level
deep enough.
Right?
So can I just say like one,
there's many,
there's,
it's a complex situation.
There's not one answer to it,
right?
You just let anybody in who's not a
criminal,
so how do we did it's hard to get in.
How do we detect that?
Like,
yeah,
we'd have to have some sort of faith in
their records so we would have to help
their record keeping.
So really what we want to really the way
to do it correctly is first of all,
anyone is attached to us,
whether it's Mexico or Canada,
make sure they're okay.
Make sure that they are viable and
stable and help them.
That's the real thing.
Treat them as if they're a colony of the
United States.
They're like,
not that they're not sovereign,
that there's still Mexico,
but like treat them like they are
connected to us and we don't want them
to be fucked up and crazy set of
building up a wall.
Make it so that nobody wants to come
over here.
Like,
that seems to be the prosperity way to
go about it.
Like to say,
Hey,
you know,
Mexico's fucking beautiful.
All right.
There's a reason why people vacation in
Mexico.
It's fucking amazing.
Okay.
You go to Poland,
Mita
or a fucking Puerto Vallarta or cabo or.
Yeah,
to loom,
there's it's fucking beautiful.
The idea that it's beautiful and also
dangerous and scary and filled with
crime.
That's fucking stupid.
So then you would go,
well,
what's the problem here?
What's the problem here is drugs.
Illegal drugs are illegal in the United
States wants to buy a bunch of drugs.
So all these people making billions of
dollars selling drugs,
there's only one way to do that.
You've got to kill cops.
You got to kill cops,
kill rats.
You gotta kill rivals.
You got to kill whoever the fuck you
gotta kill and you've got to send a
message.
You've got to hang people from fucking
bridges and shit.
Yeah,
you got to do things to send a message
that you're ruthless and you're here to
get that money and there's a lot of that
going on and that is no different than
Al Capone during the fucking prohibition
of alcohol in the United States of
America.
It's the same God damned thing.
You make something illegal that
everybody wants and only criminals are
willing to sell it and boom,
you got a thriving criminal economy.
There you go.
And so we're stuck next to a thriving
criminal economy with no management of
it whatsoever other than bullets,
right?
So occasionally they throw some bullets
into these people and then they come
back stronger than ever because there's
more drug money and there's less of
them.
And the one person gets stronger and El
Chapo digs a fucking hole,
a mile through the ground and gets out
of jail again.
The whole thing is crazy,
but this is what we're next to.
And so instead of saying,
hey,
we got to make a fucking wall and make
it.
What we should be saying is what do we
have to do to not just fix Mexico,
not just help them and come up with some
sort of strategy and a plan to build
them up almost as equals.
But we've got to fix our fucking poor
neighborhoods.
We've got to fix these fucking
neighborhoods that had been drenched in
poverty since 19 twice.
How about fix them?
Fix them,
put some energy into it.
Put some planning,
hire people the same way.
Halliburton hires people to fucking
rebuild shit.
We blow up in Iraq.
They should be hiring people to figure
out how to rebuild these communities,
figure out how to give people jobs and
figuring out how to develop community
center so that kids have somewhere to go
there where they can learn and be
productive so you're developing less
losers,
giving people hopes and dreams,
giving them things that they can put
their energy to that make them feel good
about life,
right,
give them skills and and games they can
play and things they could do where they
get good at it,
where they develop self esteem,
which is one of the most terrible things
about growing up in an impoverished
crime ridden gang infested neighborhood.
As you feel like you're nothing.
You are nothing.
Your life can be taken away at any
moment.
You got to be careful where you go,
but what's a fly and people getting
killed.
People are killing people over words and
insults and fucking territory for drugs
and your aunts on crack and your uncles
in jail and it's just seems like there's
no fucking hope and no one does anything
about it.
No one doesn't,
but few people do things about it.
A lot of people dedicate their lives to
it,
but it's not enough from a governmental
level.
No one in the top of the organization is
looking at this big thing and saying
they're all going,
hey,
we've got to drill more oil.
Hey,
we got to do with the resources,
the resources,
the reason.
What about our greatest resource human
beings?
The greatest way to make America great
again is to have less losers.
The way to have less losers is you've
got to find the spots that are sick and
healed them.
Yes.
Yeah.
Find these communities that are,
that have the momentum of poverty and
crime and violence and it's existed for
as long as we can think for decades.
Fix them,
fix them,
and have a concerted effort to fix them
and do and bring everybody together.
Everybody together and instead of this,
this idea that we're all separate and
we'll just fucking to party,
right?
Left nonsense is civil war to trump
supporters and and,
and people want to kick people out of
restaurants.
How about we all realized that if we're
going to treat each other as Americans,
we're going to agree that we're on this
team.
We got to start acting like teammates.
That's it.
Yeah,
so you don't like what the coach is
saying.
Let's let's find common ground instead
of always searching for the negative in
things instead of reinforcing ridiculous
ideas because you know that that's what
your team supports.
Like I see a lot of people online
talking about this immigrant issue and
they either don't have kids or they
don't think it could happen to their
kids.
Their ideas,
hey,
shouldn't could come over here.
You get those broke.
The law shouldn't have fucking come over
here if you didn't want to get your kid
separated.
If you were in the presence of a woman
who came over here from Guatemala and
she's poor and she's starving and
they're taking her baby away and she's
wailing and screaming from a primal,
primal place in her,
her DNA that the one thing she loves
more than anything is being taken away a
baby.
Yeah.
If you.
If that doesn't freak you the fuck out,
you're not a part of the team,
man,
you're missing it.
You're missing it.
What's,
what are we here for?
We're here for 100 years of whatever.
That's what we're here for.
If you want to spend 100 years,
say in Earth,
broke the law,
I don't want you on the team.
You're an asshole,
right?
And I'll give you.
I don't give a fuck if you're right or
left.
I don't care if you're religious or I
don't care if you're an atheist,
if that's what you support,
you are an asshole and we don't want you
on our team.
Okay?
So,
but if you agree with certain economic
policies that I don't agree with and we
could have a discussion about it,
we could figure out why you agree and we
could figure out why people are allowing
all of this money to get into politics.
Why are we allowing all these special
interest groups and lobbyists to
interfere with our laws and influence
our,
our politicians,
and create all this shit that we don't
want?
Well,
here's the number one reason.
You can't just vote online,
you can't just vote one person,
one vote.
It's the electoral college and there's a
lot of checks and balances that are in
place.
That's all wonderful and groovy,
but it's not giving the trust to the
people,
trusted the people that are.
They're informed that they could make
their own decisions,
that more people should be able to make
the decision,
but they're happening now that 28 year
old girl who who a 28 year old debt
democratic socialists,
whether I agree with her or not and I
don't know if I do or don't.
I bet I agree with her on a lot of
things.
I think education should be free.
I think we should figure out a way.
If we could pay for bombs,
we could pay for schools.
I think that this idea that everybody
should have healthcare.
It's a great idea.
Who the fuck wants people to not be
healthy?
Who wants people to be hurt and not be
able to fix it?
Who wants to do?
Are you really saying that struggling
people should have to pay exorbitant
amounts of money to get fixed when we
could maybe chip in and help members of
our team,
that stupid paper,
fill it out,
figure it out yourself on how to.
You got lucky bitch.
You got lucky.
You don't have leukemia.
You didn't break both your legs.
When you're 18,
your parents are dead.
You got lucky piece of shit.
Yeah.
These are people on our team is.
I'm not talking about people who are
lazy,
good for nothing.
Losers mooching off the system.
You're going to have that too.
Where we got to figure out how to
educate people so that that happens less
and less.
That's what we got to figure out how to
do.
That's it you just described.
I mean that is it.
I don't know what to call that thing you
just talked about,
but like that's happening everywhere.
That's not just happening in the United
States.
That's a global shift that's happening.
Have you.
Did you see the video when she found out
she won this amazing put play it.
It's like one of the rear realist
moments and look,
people are angry.
Twenty eight year olds.
What the fuck does she know what she
doesn't know?
She'll learn 20,
like,
yeah,
that's fine.
Let's find out what she learns.
Maybe she maybe she knows a lot.
I liked the fact she wasn't supposed to
win.
I like the fact that the guy who was an
incumbent was a 10 term and come back
and that he spent 10 to one verse on
her.
Then how much money she spent 10 to one
in grassroots grassroots elected man.
And that's how this.
That's it.
That can happen too.
She's a kid.
Yeah,
she's pretty.
She's a pretty young,
28 year old.
I mean watch this,
watch this shit.
When she wins,
plays it.
How are you feeling?
Can you put it into words?
You know,
I don't know if Democratic craddick
socialism is the answer,
but I know it's a part of the
conversation.
Yep.
And this is the thing that locking out
any ideology in this team as part of the
conversation,
like what is democratic socialism
entail?
Like what does it entail?
I'm,
I don't.
I don't buy all this.
The market will take care.
It's care of itself.
Bullshit.
I think there's a certain amount of us
we have to chip in to the community
pile.
Yeah,
Shit.
That's real.
The real problem is how efficient and
good is the community pile or the.
A bunch of lazy constantly community
pile are there.
Is there waste to nonsense and bullshit?
These people that have those jobs you
were talking about earlier that told
slow down,
slow down.
I know you could do this in two hours,
but you can get an eight hour day out of
this.
Don't fuck this up.
How much of that's going on?
I don't want any of that going right?
But if the community pile is taking care
of it and,
and managed in a,
in a,
uh,
an honest and a way that's trustworthy
and great for all involved and
beneficial to the community and,
and supportive of community values and
love and this idea that we're all on a
team and that you're going to be okay.
Did you break your leg,
Duncan?
Hey,
you're going to be okay and we make fun
of Canada's healthcare.
And it's not the best,
it's the best.
I have friends,
my friend Jen,
she broke her fucking knee.
She had to get a acl reconstruction.
They kind of botched it and they had to
go back in and fix it again.
She had to wait forever.
It's not the best,
but it's there.
It's something and it maybe that can be
improved.
I may be improving.
That is better.
Let me throw this in.
So have options.
But I also believe in options for people
to do it better.
Like the surgeons that you can get in
the United States.
Like there's a guy Dr Getelman to go fix
my knee.
He's a fucking wizard.
This guy's really got good.
He does a lot of pro athletes.
I mean he did a great fucking job
reconstructing my knee.
He's an artist.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with someone like that getting paid
more.
I don't think if someone was like,
I think Lebron James should get paid
more for playing basketball than me.
If I was playing basketball,
I shouldn't.
You pay as much as she's fucking way
better.
Right?
Yeah.
And I think that there's,
there's that with doctors as well,
I think with everything as well,
but I think that it's a lot like there's
a lot of people that are,
um,
a state funded prosecutors or,
or a defense attorneys,
you know,
where,
where the people can't afford it.
Uh,
you know,
you get,
what is that called?
What's the offender?
Public public defender,
yeah.
There's a lot of people that are really
good,
really good,
really young,
hungry,
very good at it.
They just,
they're,
they're going to put in their time in
the public sector or doing it for,
for the public public defender.
And then they eventually go onto maybe,
maybe even not do that.
Maybe they just did.
They get satisfaction out of helping
people that don't have any money.
That doesn't mean that you shouldn't
have high priced lawyers as well.
And it doesn't mean that people
shouldn't be able to pursue excellence
and be rewarded for that excellence and
be able to do whatever the fuck they
want with it.
Whether they want to be charitable with
that money or where they want to be
selfish with that money.
If they're pursuing excellence and
through their excellence they did.
They managed to amass an extreme amount
of wealth doing playing the guitar,
whatever the fuck they do.
There's nothing wrong with that either.
We've got to stop thinking there's
something wrong with that,
but chipping in and everybody putting
into the company,
pop is in a sense some form of
socialism,
right?
Like we agree on some kind of socialism
like is when you consider like the fire
department,
the police department.
It's just like social things,
right?
We put money into it.
It's not a total redistribution of
wealth like deciding how much rich
people should pay,
but it is deciding you got to chip in.
We all got to chip in.
Everybody's got a chip.
I just don't feel like the chip and in
is good.
We feel like it's all fucked up.
We feel like there's a bunch of dummies
out there like this jeff sessions guy.
That guy gets paid for my chip.
This fucking dummy and all these fucking
people that are robbing the system with
their two hour a day jobs that they're
stretching out to eight hours.
That builds resentment.
It's poor management and it's also
people that are listless and they have
these.
They're not valuable jobs and not like a
job that commands the same sort of
attention is like some of the more
attractive jobs that people seek out.
Yeah,
man,
I,
I.
it's all of it's true.
I just think it's,
it's the what people think is let's wait
for the government to do this
and that's where I think the problem is
like instead of thinking like,
okay,
yeah,
all that's true.
Let's like figure out a way to get more
taxpayer money out of the military
industrial complex out of the prisons.
It,
let's put it in the neighborhoods that
need it.
Let's get it for funding education,
all of that is really beautiful,
but when it's still in and you want to
vote and make all that happen,
grassroots movements,
all of it,
but also think of the term socialism,
right?
Just what is it?
Social.
It's like you don't have to wait for the
state to come and start figuring out
ways to tax people to make that pile of
money happened.
Like this is.
This is where I think it's an
interesting thing to start exploring the
idea of intentional communities.
I'm not saying starting a commune or
anything like that,
but you can actually push your
friendship group to the next level.
Like it doesn't just have to be a random
group of friends who knows each other.
Like you can start that pile of opulence
with a group of friends where it's like,
you know what I mean?
A group of friends can just agree with
each other like,
hey man,
just so you know,
you're not going to be homeless.
I got you.
I'm not going to fucking give you money
all the Goddamn time.
And if you like,
you know,
if you're like,
you don't even have to say any of this
shit except hey,
we're.
This is always okay.
You're okay.
Gotcha.
Right.
That's what you and I did when you moved
in with Joe.
I know man,
and I forget about that sometimes.
We lived together for like six months.
I don't forget about it.
And,
and,
and the,
the,
um,
that kind of thing,
which is what I'm saying is like
everyone right now and,
and I understand why I'm in,
but to me there seems to be something
demonic about the public fixation on the
state.
It's the state.
Is this like dragon and it's like got
like,
it's a.
well,
I think it's a daddy.
It's a daddy.
It's a multi-arm daddy with a bunch of
fucking laser pointers that it's got the
entire population watching like cats
running around.
Right,
right.
God,
they did that.
Oh my God,
he did that.
they did that.
When will this change?
When will this change
your phone's ringing gas.
Who's fucking calling your dad?
When was the last time you talked to
your dad?
Three months ago.
Call Your fucking dad back the whole
time you were like,
God,
yeah.
Did Dr Dre
the whole time you're neglecting your
family.
You're neglecting your neighborhood.
You're walking down the street looking
at your phone like,
holy fuck.
He said that.
Oh,
I'm writing a fucking blog about that.
Guess what,
you're walking by dude,
you're walking by fucking plastic
bottles,
piles of fucking trash,
three fucking mathematics in some
fucking woman who just got beaten by her
husband is now living on the streets
for the last couple of weeks and you've
got fucking $40,000
in the bank account.
Liquid.
And when I say that to the garden you
can touch.
Yes,
yes.
Tend to the garden.
You can touch and do it in an organized
way and then like maybe a,
but don't you have a garden that you can
touch this giant or you think about
that.
Think about what you've done during this
podcast and some of the things that
you've said.
You basically touched an enormous
garden.
Sure.
That,
that's,
that's one.
That's a really easy way to do it
because I'm a Yappy motherfucker.
I'm talking about like,
no in your life too,
but that counts too.
I think it does count,
but I think that it's,
it would be easy to do things like that
and,
and still forget about something that's
really basic,
which is now that I'm talking about that
shit,
I'm thinking to myself right now,
like in my neighborhood,
I'm thinking like,
wait a minute,
wait,
what am I not doing?
I don't know what it is yet,
but I guarantee you there's something
that I could do.
And,
and I liked that man because he knew
like tithing to the church.
Yes.
So to me that I think we may have talked
about this before but I get it and all
but like it always seemed like a really
boring way to do it.
Like the plate comes by,
you throw some money and you don't.
It goes to church stuff you don't know.
But the idea of tithing,
I think there's something to it which is
like if you just kind of look at your
income and you think,
all right,
five percent of this shit is gonna get
spent or 10 percent or whatever you're
comfortable with.
I'm putting that in a pile and that pile
is going to helping people in my
neighborhood or my friends or my family
and I'm just going to give that away.
And um,
I think there's something to be said for
that because right now I think we were a
little too fixated on the daddy state
helping us and I think it's more
important that we start helping each
other and forming communities with that
are based on love and friendship and
just figure it out.
Some of the communities are going to
fail,
some of them are going to get a couple
of assholes in there who are con artists
and trick.
Everybody are lazy people.
But the main thing is,
is like let's start thinking in terms of
organizing into communities that aren't
based on a fixation on the government
right now.
And then let's see what happens.
And with that,
ladies and gentlemen,
we conclude another episode of the Joe
Rogan experience.
I'd like to thank my guests,
Duncan Trussell,
praise Odin,
Heidi young,
Jamie on the mic and the work of the
keys in the background.
And all of you folks love you,
love for everybody.
We can do this,
folks.
We doing it.
We're doing this.
We're going to be okay.
Bye.